give me just a moment and I'll get the
just so you know I'm looking at the
list of speakers that testify our cat
and I and I have zero
that have asked to testify so
um
I'm a little uh
concerned about that so
we can talk about that once we get
started do you is someone there to
yeah all right we're all set to start
well good morning
this was the municipal and County
government committee
and we are here today to hear several
bills this morning and we'll be working
uh into the afternoon as we go into
executive session on several builds as
well
so before we get started though uh I
have a uh some notes I need to to share
with you about this process and how it
works
especially for the public to understand
as chair of the municipal and County
government committee I find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covid-19
pandemic in accordance with house rule
67 and the governor's emergency order
number 12 is doing to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee an executive
session may follow at any time
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however
and according to the emergency order I
am confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
has the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar
under General Court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
in the event that the public is unable
to access this meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and and then reschedule
Christina Dyer is the staff assisting us
thank you Christina and please note that
all votes that are taken during this
meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
so let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please State
whether it's if you are if you are
connected electronically whether there's
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is requiring under the
right to know law
I turned to the clerk and asked for a
roll call
uh thank you Mr chairman representative
Dolan yeah
representative giamonte yeah
Clark is here
I think he's going to be uh
okay uh representative
representative
here
representative power
here I'm present at my home in Brookline
in my office alone however there are two
other household members in other parts
of the house
thank you representative Porter
okay
I'm pressing in my home in Hillsboro I'm
alone in the room but my husband is in
the house
thank you representative
tree 11.
good morning I'm here in Dover New
representative Gilman
good morning I am here in Exeter I am
alone in the room but my husband may be
representative majority
I am here I am alone in my office and I
have sent an invite over to
representative Melvin just to be sure I
don't see him in the list of attendees
okay thank you representative Davis
I am present here in my home in Lebanon
representative magaputi
good morning I am here in Nashua in our
representative fan I am here in my house
in Peterborough New Hampshire and there
I am alone in the room but there are two
other people in the house in other rooms
I am here
um in the room I'm sorry in Nashua
um in my room currently alone my husband
is in the house I do wear headset so he
cannot hear the conversation
I'm here in my apartment in Concord and
I am alone
thank you I'm Mr chairman I show two
members absent
thank you uh
at the start I'd like to ask you all to
all right so today we have uh several
bills
you know what they're going to move
right along and this particular uh bill
this is uh what you may see as a
cat referred to as a cacker which is a
constitutional amendment uh if this uh
does make it to the house there's a
point of information it will require a
60 percent
of both the path
if this is not the 51 percent
we do have by the way on our sign up
sheet or support or not support we have
uh four who have signed up to support it
it's 40 have signed up to oppose it
and zero on neutral on it
and we're going to ask representative
Roy
uh to introduce the bill do you have
representative manager do you have
representative
I do and he is allowed to talk he should
be all set hey representative Roy the
microphone in New York welcome
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee
I am here to rep uh to introduce this
morning csm9 my name is uh
representative Terry Roy I represent
Rockingham 32.
this Constitutional Amendment
um would
restrict municipalities from Raising
property taxes
more than two percent in any given year
for the general population and more than
one percent in any given year for
disabled residents or senior citizens
I feel that we can all agree that one of
the main complaints or issues or
concerns that all of our constituents
have Democrat Republican independent is
the rising and ever increasing cost of
property taxes in the state
now
I could have been given the speech to
this committee probably 30 years ago and
it would have been the same exact thing
we seem to be
grappling with this for decades and we
don't know how to deal with it
and while we kick the can down the road
and by we I don't mean us perhaps
sitting here but our predecessors and
their predecessors before them
the people who are really paying for are
the citizens who are or owning property
and in particularly senior citizens we
are without
um a doubt in arguably
taxing senior citizens out of their
homes
um there there's people I've heard from
constituents that have to sell their
homes that they've lived in their whole
lives and worked their whole careers to
pay for because they can no longer
afford their property taxes
now
we can debate whose fault that is but I
think that that's another that's another
issue but in the meantime you know it's
kind of like first stage you got to stop
believing we have to put the brakes on
this and force us to have a conversation
as a legislature in municipalities how
to deal with this property tax issue and
if we don't do something to stop it it's
just going to keep going and going
so Massachusetts over 30 years ago
introduced something called proposition
two and a half and similarly it froze
two and a half percent as a property tax
cap
um
we as a legislature would not be doing
this all this is is enabling the
citizens of the state to have a say
so if we were to pass this it wouldn't
it wouldn't go into effect what it would
do was put on the ballot and it would
let the citizens of the state come out
and say yeah we we agree it should be
Frozen at a certain level or no we don't
agree
um so I think it's time the citizens how
to say in this property tax situation
and the problem has been
um part of it
that people don't really understand how
town meeting Works we've kind of failed
Civics wise and for many of us even even
legislators aren't really sure how it
works and if you can't go to town
meeting or if you don't understand how
it works
you just realize when you get your tax
bill oh my God taxes have gone up yet
again
so what this would do if the citizens
chose to pass it
would be it would freeze the property
tax a two percent increase over the
previous year's tax
but they would be able to override that
if the municipality can make a
convincing argument to their citizens
why it needed to go up
there's a mechanism to override the two
percent and the citizens can vote to do
so all this does is keep the
municipality
from putting it forward without the
citizens direct approval on a ballot
where they can actually see what it
means instead of at a town meeting in
the middle of the night with a raise of
hands or years and days when people
don't even know what's happening or
understand how to how to navigate it
so what I want to do with this is I'm
hoping we can start a conversation that
we've been avoiding for for decades on
how to help out our our citizens with
this property tax issue and while we're
doing it protect senior citizens and
disabled people from losing their homes
because they just can no longer afford
these tax increases
again I just want to reiterate if we
pass this it doesn't mean it goes into
effect all this does is say
citizens in New Hampshire
this is what we've come up with to offer
you are you interested or not and it's
up to them devoted to pass it all this
is is really enabling
the citizens to have a voice
so with that I'd be happy to take any
questions
okay
um before we get the questions we're
going to ask representative manager if
you could co-host me for the really
Christina to do that
at this point I believe I need Christina
Dyer's assistance there if she can
okay so maybe she can work on that while
uh
we'll first go to uh representative
corner at our hand rates first
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative Roy
when I see things like this I get a
little bit concerned and I don't
understand how it would work in this
situation Grant it it's a hypothetical
but say there was a natural disaster
that wiped out the school buildings in a
community for a fire it was a flood
there was a landslide and the and the
school was completely gone
it would cause and that in order to do
so taxes needed to be raised more than
if you say that there's a provision in
here that could be overridden if the
taxpayers agree but what if the
taxpayers didn't agree what if it went
to the voters and and they decided no
they had to wait for the town meeting
and then they voted no we're not going
to let you do that what would happen how
would the community deal with
this situation if it's again if it's in
the Constitution that they can't change
it they can't go over two percent
um thank you for the question
representative Porter but I I kind of um
without being cheeky think you answered
the question for me the community would
have spoken when they said no we're not
going to do that I mean so that
I'm sorry no I guess the question is how
would the the
in other words the elected officials of
the Town how would they be able to
override their own citizens and
constituents and say we know better than
you we do need this school so I I guess
I guess the problem is is again I want
the citizens to be able to have the say
in the matter and I would I would submit
I I would hope that they would want to
replace the school
um in that situation but having said
that if they didn't
um
I really I mean
you can't I don't think we're in the
business of forcing them to do what they
don't want to do and people would then I
guess vote with their feet and leave the
town that did not want to replace at
school
um but I that's really hypothetical
no it just seems to me that we're
putting the town if the vote was close
and it was 51 to 49 percent
that means almost half the people want
to replace their school
what
is the recourse then that just have to
well I I guess
I guess I'm looking at a bigger picture
I mean the same thing applies in 51
voted for a certain President 50 didn't
and we end up with the president we get
I mean that's the way the Democracy
works but I can see your point you know
when you get into a really small town
one uh one anti-government curmudgeon
might be able to to flip the vulpit
again that's just how democracy works
and I think if we don't give the
citizens a choice to vote and say you
know uh I am in favor or not in favor
um it's us it's us
um dictating to them what they're gonna
what they're gonna have and what they're
not and what they're going to pay and
what they're not and again I would
remind you that it's it's the senior
citizens and the disabled people who are
going to foot this bill it's not really
it's the Young Folks working are able to
keep up with these increases every year
hardly but they are better than people
who get you know fourteen hundred
dollars a month Social Security when you
get that kind of money and you see a 500
or 600 increase on your taxes you're
talking about percentages of your yearly
income and these are the folks I think
we really need to save here while these
debates occur such as what you just
discussed
thank you
next uh representative I'm going to go
to representative Gallagher and then and
then after that representative
for two purposes so you know next up
here from our representative Gallagher
here microphone endurance
so
um you were describing in your testimony
how this would work in a town meeting
for
um places that municipalities that are
organized as towns
um I'm from Concord I represent a city
we don't do Town meetings we do
um we have a city council and mayor and
city manager how
would
that situ How would
this Amendment affect cities with
uh city government
organized in that manner
uh thank you for the question
representative Gallagher I I only
mentioned town meeting because that's
the one that's really confusing for a
lot of people especially folks that move
from out of state or from cities like
yourself don't really a lot of them
don't understand the process but it
doesn't specify in the amendment
um town city or whatever just as a
municipality so for example if Concord
wanted to raise property taxes uh three
percent one year they would need to go
to the voters of Concord for an override
to be able to do that so it really would
be no different for a town or a city
thank you uh we're gonna go to next to
representative manager Cody and then
thank you
representative Roy for taking my
question for me it
um kind of brings a very fundamental
question about Democratic process uh
voters elect us to represent their View
and they hold us accountable hopefully
to carry their you know I get emails and
calls from my
and uh to say the due diligence and what
to me in the process this seems to be
putting it right back to the voters and
saying you make the decision how you
want to uh raise uh revenue or pay for
the taxes you know I will only
facilitate
and then why do we have to go through
the process of electing you if my
constituents ask that kind of question
how do I respond uh
that this is as a role for me is that's
why we get the big bucks paid and the
big title of State reps so just if you
can address that oh I'd be happy to and
I'd also be happy if you'd share some of
those big bucks because I didn't seem to
get my check this year from the
legislature
um so this is we're talking about
democracy at the at the closest level so
for state representatives we don't we
don't set tax rates for towns
um it would be their local local local
local Representatives on their town
councils on their City councilors
um and and at that level
the voters always get a chance to vote
on a budget
and what happens is a lot in
increasingly so across the state they
end up with something called a default
budget in other words they do vote down
the increases
um but it really doesn't help because
the default budget's almost the same as
the budget anyway because of contractual
obligations and a myriad of other things
all this does is say it gives the it
gives them one more chance to say no to
a tax increase so I don't think that
we're we're abrogating our
responsibility or we're deflecting it
back to the taxpayers because at our
level
we don't get involved in the in the
exact in the rate setting for the towns
for the state representative level all
we're doing is saying to the people in
the cities and towns
we're going to give you one more chance
to approve or not approve the tax
increase is being proposed by the
municipality
I hope that answers your question a
oh no I understand so this but we have
to work together the state downshifts to
the counties and the cities and the
towns so that is our role or I see
myself as uh you know facilitating that
or
uh advocating for my constituency not
downshifting and tax rates are set local
level I understand that but how we
facilitate state has a big say in how it
facilitates uh how it directs so from
that angle
takes away
um
okay I'll I'll take that as a question I
think
um so I'm glad you said that well first
of all two things I'm sure you probably
understand that you and I probably
disagree fundamentally on the whole
downshifting thing but but that's good
though because this gives us this would
give us that conversation we can't we've
been we've been having that debate
between one side and the other about
downshifting and whose responsibility is
it's been going on for decades and it
will continue to go on after you and I
are no longer in the house I think it's
time that we stop kicking the can and we
force ourselves to have the conversation
so if municipalities can no longer raise
revenue however to whatever extent they
want while we fight about who's going to
pay for it
we're going to have to be forced to the
table and it's going to force us to come
to some kind of an agreement on how to
help municipalities if we just continue
having the finger pointing downshifting
we'll know it's your responsibility
argument it's just going to continue on
forever and ever well in the meantime as
I said in my opening statement senior
citizens are being forced out young
people can't move in the taxes are just
too darn High to borrow a statement
so I I think that it's good that we have
that debate about whose responsibility
it is but the people are suffering while
we debate are the citizens so all I'm
saying here is let the citizens have a
chance to say no we're not paying for
that now you who I elected figure out
how to help us because in the meantime
all that's happening is the cities and
towns just keep saying the state's
downshifting we have to raise the taxes
and the state's saying well we don't
have any money and to to raise the money
we'd have to raise taxes on businesses
so while we have that debate let's save
the citizens and it'll Force us to have
let me think of a moment here
I look at my screen I'd like to see some
thumbs up the quality of the sound that
you're hearing can you hear me well
give me a thumbs up if you can hear me
okay thank you uh and look we have
several Representatives on the committee
who's RN cue to speak we'll be going
through representative power next and
then representative Gilman uh and then
we have several more viewed up let me uh
just uh suggest that at this point in
the process you should be asking those
who are testifying any questions to help
us understand the bill and the intent of
the bill and uh
the time for debate of the uh of the
bill will actually be during the
executive session
so uh as as emotional or as passionate I
guess it's a better word as many many
people are around some of these issues I
want to ask you to try not to debate the
issue with the with the individual is
testifying just ask questions about the
bill to get a better understanding of it
and we'll have a healthy debate during
the Executive Center but at this point
I'd like to go to representative power
and then we'll go to representative
field after that
thank you chairman Dolan and thank you
representative Roy for taking my
question I have two questions and I'm
happy to go to the end of the line on my
second question that would be up to the
chair
so my first question is with regard to
the override
um representative Roy could you qualify
what the override
um would look like is there a statute to
reference I'm aware of a tax cap
override as well as the 10 rule override
did you um you know explain what the
threshold would be for that override
vote thank you
um I believe as written in the um in the
proposed amendment
it indicates that they will be a ballot
election to vote on the override so
um if a town suggests a tax increase for
whatever whatever reason they would
um they would create a ballot with that
question on it and that would clearly
explain the amount of the override and
why
yeah thank you I I do see that it's it's
a two-thirds threshold that was my um
oversight and should I go to the end of
the line for my second question chair
right now
so the second question is I was just
wanting to understand the rationale for
the two Provisions in the bill one for
the general
um
I guess taxpayer or public and the
second
um one for the certain disabled citizens
and those older than 67 years old why
the difference in the two percent and
the one percent
um tax cap if you will sure thank you
for that question
um the way I see it in many of my
constituents have voiced this to me is
that when you have a job and you're
gainfully employed
you can reasonably expect or hope to to
get raises to opportunities to increase
your income
um to to at least match if not exceed
the the property tax increases
when you are a disabled person living on
social security or you're over 67 and
retired living on Social Security you're
on a fixed income there there are no
increases if there are it's less than
one percent you know um and if you have
a one percent increase in your income
and a five percent increase in your
taxes you've actually lost money so I
picked people who were on a fixed income
with no opportunity to to increase that
so a disabled person can say you know
what I'm going to go out and get a
second job so I can afford these taxes
they're not allowed to work or they
can't work a senior citizen same thing
um you know someone who's worked 30 and
40 years and finally made retirement
they're on a fixed income and they just
have no way to to increase their income
to match the property taxes that's why I
made their cap lower than people who
work or or at least assumably are able
to create more Revenue
thank you next we have uh representative
filament and after that we'll go to
Birmingham
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
represent representative Roy for taking
my question
um I would like to clarify that this
bill says uh
that the tax cap is on the actual amount
of taxes paid not on the tax rate is
that true yes that is correct it's on
the actual tax from the year before not
on the tax rate the rate is set it's
totally separate than the actual
taxation amount
um follow-up Mr chair
go ahead
so
if that's the case are you concerned at
all about uh decrease in the services
that a town can supply because their the
revenue is
flat or not enough to cover
what we currently have
um well I I would let me speak to it as
a citizen of my town
um yeah if if it was put to me as a
citizen and a voter saying look if we
can't raise three percent this year
we're going to lose a cruiser we're
going to lose an officer we're going to
lose a fire truck
that would be something that would
concern me and that would be something
that I would talk to my family and
community members about and we as a
community would decide whether or not to
to override the cap so that we could
maintain the level of services that we
have
um but I would also want as a citizen to
be able to say you know what
um I think that that while that service
is important it's not important enough
for me to not be able to afford uh my
medicare this year my medical insurance
this year you know as a senior citizen a
lot of our senior citizens are making
choices between food and and heat and
things of this nature so it's it's you
know it's I don't want to say it's easy
for us but it's easier for us to sit
back and say well you know we need to
have these services but there are people
out there that are literally
um heating their houses with their oven
because they can't afford the oil Bill
and they they want to pay their taxes
because they'll lose their house so I
mean these these These are tough tough
conversations and tough decisions to
happen I don't want to make light to
them but we have to do something to let
the citizens at least have a say if they
decide you know what we we need that
service we want to raise the tax they
can do so but it also says lets them
have the ability to say no
LaSalle
uh thank you um for for taking my uh
comments in question uh representative
Roy
um first I'd like to disclose
there's a couple of things one is I am
an alderman as well as a State Rep I'm
an alderman in the city of Nashua I'm
also one of those people that
um not currently goodness but who has
heeded my house with wood burning stoves
and kept my food on a side porch because
I didn't during the winter time because
I didn't have enough money to fix a um a
refrigerator so I truly do understand
I'm also on a fake thinking so I
understand what
um elderly disabled Etc people go
my comment or question I should say is
um two things well I do have one more
comment and I apologize for taking so
much time but the tax rates actually are
set by the dra in Concord and yes it is
based on the budget that is submitted by
the city but it is
um the rate itself is actually set by
Concord and not by this city
um the taxes that are paid include the
tax rates for the schools the tax rate
for the county and then the tax rate
that's set by the dra for the um the
cities now having said that I can tell
you that um in in Nashua
quite often and I'm sure this is through
the entire State Municipal elections
don't bring out a lot of Voters
people who are passionate will come out
so my concern is that you mentioned
right up from the beginning that
sometimes citizens aren't knowledgeable
about town meetings
well that's a town meet
me
where they can vote on a budget and so
on in the cities the municipalities it
doesn't quite work that way we would
literally have to have a special
election to kind of get this on a ballot
or I would have to wait two years for
the next ballot has that been taken into
consideration
um
that the lack of citizen participation
oftentimes in the Municipal elections as
well as
how you would have to put this on the
ballot to override
um I guess that's my my comment and
thank you for taking my question
thank you representative clay
um actually I I did take that into
consideration regarding voter
participation and I I actually hope this
would drive up voter participation I
think that if the voters actually had a
choice to say hey if you don't show up
with the polls your taxes going up and
if you don't show up you know you had a
chance
um so I I hope that it would actually
drive higher participation greater
interest in what the towns and cities
are spending the money on and actually
drive citizen engagement and maybe in a
positive way they might learn you know
what
um I I my taxes are going to go up
because they they need this or they need
that and they go look and they say you
know what they do need this I actually
now that I look at it whereas before
they may have just sat home and said
yeah they're always asking for something
so I I hope that it drives a greater
Civic engagement and greater
participation at the polls
um with regard to passing it um and I
I'm actually a member of my Municipal
budget committee so I I kind of have an
idea of what this is too
um
as far as special elections and things
like gecko I'm not sure as far as how
the City Works
um with regard to their budget if this
the city uh they if they vote on your
budget or not or if it's just passed
then that's it I know in the town
um we vote on the budget
um so it really would just be that if
they knew that the budget was going to
exceed it two percent as part of the
regular voting they would just put that
on the ballot and and that would be that
I'm not sure if the city would require a
special election to do it or not
um but again it's
keep in mind that if we pass this the
the the
citizens get to decide whether they want
this or not so if they decide you know
that's too complicated or too expensive
to do it they won't do it
thank you so much
um I I guess my follow-up would be
um on the surface we we often say that
um
the citizens are request it is educated
and they listen to us they listen to
advertisers and and so on about so if
you're hit with do you do you not want
your taxes to go up
um
I think the average person this is my
opinion but um would say no I I'll do
anything to make sure my taxes going up
not understanding the ramifications and
then again once that ramification hits
we have to cut Services Etc because we
can't go up more than two percent
overall in one percent
um on senior citizens and I can tell you
from my district I have a lot of senior
citizens that we give senior citizen
credits to and um and so on so we reduce
their taxes
um I'm afraid that we might have to get
rid of that if we did something like
this because this in fact would do that
but don't you feel that
um anybody would and I guess the
rhetorical question want to save money
and therefore might vote
um their wallet versus
um what may be considered common sense I
mean objective remember this is the
our opinions you know debate to go
I know I know people feel strongly about
I
I understand that so so uh but I just as
you think as you're about to speak uh
especially those that are still on the
list try to perform your comment in the
film of a question as opposed to here's
my opinion of of the bill and so forth
we will have plenty of time here in
executive session to go through
how we feel in the opinions of that so I
I don't mean to interrupt uh
representative plea I just want to try
to make sure that we're staying on track
if you could have some some final
follow-up you'd like to offer no no and
I would like to apologize for having
interjected an opinion I do know better
than that um thank you very much for the
time I'd be happy to respond to her last
um her last question
um
with regard to the the citizen education
and and stuff I would hope that this
this bill I think it's our job
um part of our job is to is to be
um Educators if you will in Civics for
our for our constituents rather than say
you know I'm afraid you really don't
know the ramifications of what you're
going to do so I'm going to do it for
you I think it's our job to say and
explain and educate our constituents
um on on what we do and the
ramifications of a vote I guess that's I
I would uh
for human purposes we're going to next
go to representative lasalles who's here
representative
thank you uh representative Roy for
taking my question uh I question
concerns the basis of the uh limit the
cap on the previous year's test taxes
uh we just went through a revaluation in
my town and based upon the revaluation
some people's taxes went up some
people's taxes went down if you base the
tax cap on the previous year's taxes in
some cases
people who had a a
revaluation that went down would be
could possibly be hit by a bigger tax
while somebody's
revaluation that went up wouldn't be
eligible for any tax increase so how
well if I'm understanding a question
correctly I I think if if a tax in a
previous year for example
is was one thousand dollars
the next year's tax could not increase
by more than
um
uh ten dollars that would be a twenty
percent
um if I'm doing math right
um so it regardless of one if someone
had to decrease the year before or not
the question is what could the increase
be the next year and that's all that
this would control is is the increase
for the next year
um based on the previous year so if if
someone's taxes went up or down the year
before I I think that it would be um
irrelevant to the to the amendment
because it only addresses how much the
increase would be for the the current
year
next uh I give the microphone
representative for 11 and then after
that representative
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
um
representative Roy for taking my
question I noted in your intro that you
mentioned dealing with the property the
ever increasing property tax
um and I'm wondering if you considered
any other Alternatives uh because
from my point of view where I sit here
reading the bill this deals with a small
number of people in our state
to attack what is a very large problem
for a lot of people in our state and I
wonder wondering if you thought of any
other Alternatives besides this specific
one
um if I could answer with start with a
question when you when you say a small
number of people could you explain what
you mean by that
um well the majority of our population
is not senior citizens
and the majority of our population is
not disabled people although they are
prevalent in our state by a small number
I meant a specific subset of citizens
okay senior citizens and disabled
persons
well sure the the amendment covers
actually everybody it freezes cap at two
percent the one percent cap is for
senior citizens and disabled people I
met excuse me I misunderstood thank you
very much that's all I need okay thank
you
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Roy for taking my
question that's a two-part question
really
um and the first part is um
questioning your reference to
Massachusetts proposition two and a half
um Massachusetts also has an income tax
isn't that correct
yes so so property taxes is not the only
source of Revenue that the state derives
yeah yeah so I just wanted to clarify
that from my own memory of living in
Massachusetts many many years ago
um and for others who may not be aware
um secondly uh could I answer could I
expound on my answer please different
please and I'm sorry to interrupt no
that's okay
um being a refugee from Massachusetts
myself I can speak to so that they have
quite a few uh revenue streams uh
property tax sales tax excise tax
um there's there's taxes for everything
um but
your municipalities do not benefit from
your income taxes other than state aid
which we also provide and
um
so the municipalities derived the the
majority of their income for their
services and police departments and fire
etc etc schools from property taxes so
um it it is comparable in that aspect
but the state itself has much more
Revenue to Dole out in state aid than we
do so yes right and to fulfill its
obligations to the municipalities
um my question has to do with
well I'll just make it very specific to
the city of Lebanon the city of Lebanon
has a very high rate of Taxation however
we are dominated by tax-exempt
institutions and one of those tax exempt
institutions is a hospital that serves
all of the people of New Hampshire
Vermont Maine and many in Massachusetts
how would this Constitutional Amendment
affect
municipalities that are dominated by
tax-exempt institutions and Lebanon is
not the only one and those tax-exempt
institutions serve many more people than
the people who live in those
municipalities
well the the amendment doesn't doesn't
address taxation for people who aren't
taxed so it really wouldn't impact that
at all but it sounds like it sounds like
that would be a different piece of
legislation that would need to deal with
tax-exempt organizations
um but this this is only for for people
residents who pay taxes
and since those organizations don't it
really I don't uh maybe I'm missing the
point in your question and I'd be happy
to to take it again if if I'm not
answering your question well my I guess
the point of my question is that there
are municipalities in New Hampshire
um whose tax base is affected by the
presence of tax exempt institutions that
serve the entire population of the state
and other states as well not just by
that into a question
well I believe I did and my question
originally was how did representative
Roy you know how do you see
municipalities like Lebanon that have a
substantial amount of tax-exempt
property in them as well as high numbers
of elderly and disabled people paying
high property taxes
how do you think this Constitutional
Amendment might affect
those municipalities that really have no
control
over a lot of the land in there
well I I guess I would I would stick
with my original answer that that it
wouldn't it wouldn't change the the
landscape
of of who pays tax and who doesn't pay
Stacks if if
if there's an issue and this is again
I'm happy for to have these
conversations because it's it makes us
talk about revenue streams and and if if
there needs to be legislation to fix
that uh tax exempt issue then then let's
have that discussion too
um but I don't think your senior
citizens and disabled folks should have
to carry the weight when you have a an
organization like that that could pay
more taxes and help them out so again
let's let's save them
while we figure out what to do and this
forces us to have that conversation
thank you thank you
okay next we're going to go to
representative McDonald here in the uh
LLP and then representative manager
thank you uh representative Roy for
taking my question
doesn't the power to do what your bill
wants to do as far as setting the
percentages
within the local communities if someone
wants to do a long article and having
the people vote on that to limit that
increase
folks
thank you for taking my question
representative Roy
doesn't the power to do what you want to
do in your bill exists the local
community if someone in a group of 25
more people wanted to go on article
to limit the tax rate going up two
percent or three percent uh couldn't
they do that locally rather than having
a constitutional amendment
um you know I I'm not sure whether that
would be legal or not but let's assume
for the sake of discussion it is
um in the very next election uh 25 more
people could come back and change it
back again or raise it even higher what
the amendment would do would take that
out of and again especially for towns
where you have Town meetings and and you
know there's there's a whole it's a it's
it's an interesting culture there's a
whole strategy behind telling readings
um you know dragging them out as late as
possible to see who goes home before
calling certain votes and and a lot of
that's complicated and it's very New
England and it's awesome but it's
difficult on senior citizens disabled
people to sit at a town meeting all
night to make sure that their taxes
don't go up so I agree with you
um in principle a town could set up
Warren article to freeze their taxes I'm
not sure about the legality of it but
um the very next town meeting um it
could be reversed and if you can't keep
that number of people there to make sure
that doesn't happen again in the middle
of the night
um
you know that's what you end up with
which is why I feel like if it's in the
Constitution
um it sets it sets running rules for
municipalities and it puts the power
back in the in the um in the citizens
hands and lets them decide whether or
not they actually need an increase or
not
good yes thank you
I representative Matt Yuri is next and
then I believe we have representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Roy for taking my
question uh I am one of the Selectmen
here in Northampton and I've sat in the
collective bargaining agreements for uh
for my town and the school and I'm
curious if this tax cap could put us at
risk of running afoul of bargaining in
good faith if for some reason the town
felt that we could not
if we could not execute or if we could
not negotiate
a contract because of uh the approach to
to that number uh would we be in some
could we be in some legal trouble uh and
and consider that we are not bargaining
in good faith
have you considered that or do you do
you see any risk there I actually have
considered that um interesting short
story
um when proposition two and a half
passed in Massachusetts I was a wee lad
and my um my father was a police officer
and I remember the police Union
um fighting that tooth and nail and all
the unions fighting it because of uh
they had a mandatory arbitration I
believe at the time and what happened
was once this passed
um there was no question about
bargaining in good faith because it's
simply the the Constitution prohibited
uh any any race that would go over that
cap so it is the Constitution would
supersede anything
contractually or bargaining in good
faith um
situations like that because you just
don't have the ability to bargain any
higher than that
thank you
and next we have well before we go to
representative 11 after uh after her I'd
like to go to the public
if there's anybody that wants to speak
that that
uh
through the zoom software if you're just
listening over the telephone you can
raise your hand and indicate to me that
you want to speak by hitting star six
so uh representative managuri our
s
thank you Mr chair and thanks
representative Roy for hearing me again
and sorry for my misunderstanding I've
only read the bill like 16 times what I
what I want to ask well my real question
at the base of all of it is did you
think of any alternative methods to deal
with our ever increasing property taxes
here in the state of New Hampshire
yeah I've I've actually um
I I fought a lot I it's
it's probably all I think about since
I've been elected is how to fix this and
I'm sure the same applies to everyone I
see on this Hollywood Squares in front
of me
um you know the question is do we need a
new Revenue stream
um do how do we handle it do we but why
that debate I think is for us to have
and uh for us to have rather quickly
and I think that this Constitutional
Amendment will force us to have that
debate
um because you're going to have people
saying hey we need to raise taxes more
and you're we need to have this service
and that service and you're going to
have people saying hey this is great we
don't need any more taxes
um I I feel like this this will force us
to finally stop kicking the can down the
road and figure out how best to handle
funding issues in this state that at the
end of the day while while the red and
the blue team are up here kicking each
other the people down there are are
having so I mean it just breaks my heart
to see senior citizens have to sell
their family home I I just you know it
really makes it difficult to sleep at
night to see
um senior citizens in a grocery store
having to put car items back because
they're like Jesus I can't afford that
this week knowing that we're
municipalities are taking that money
and um it's it's just I think we need
that we need to we need to put the
brakes on this while we figure it out
and force ourselves to figure it out
follow-up Mr chair yeah
thank you representative Roy I hear you
loud and clear
um
yet I wonder
if
changing the Constitution of our state
is the actual way to start a
conversation about how we support one
another
is that a question
yes
is changing the Constitution of our
state mandating something for our entire
State a way to start a conversation
well um I'll I'll entertain that I think
I think we've tried to start the
conversation haven't we
um over and over and over again uh with
different different you know do we need
a sales tax do we need an income tax do
we need this do we need that we've had
these conversations and we've had them
for decades
um
and both sides have an opinion and we're
pretty well entrenched in our opinions
and and the the line doesn't move in the
meantime while we're while we're we're
having a conversation at this level the
people who are living at the real level
are suffering um so I think we can take
a pause in our never-ending conversation
to help them out and just maybe that'll
Force us to no longer
um we're gonna have to someone's gonna
have to cross the line somewhere and
we're gonna have to figure out a
solution
thank you for your answer
thank you
we have a couple more Representatives
that have additional questions
we do not Mr chair
okay let's go to representative
so
um
my questions about the separability of
different Provisions within the
amendment
um I'm just
um you know hearing both sides of this
debate I'm wondering about potential
uh
Avenues towards compromise and um
I I support disability rights so I'm
glad you
made a
car route to give disabled people a
lower rate but I'm also sensitive to the
concerns that my colleagues have raised
so I'm wondering if you'd be open to
amendments to your amendment to say
just do the portion for people with
disabilities or if
um you're insisting that it passed the
past asteroid in
well um thank you representative for the
question as you know that the it's your
bill now
um so if you if you choose to amend it
um that that would be up to you I I
would rather see it stay as written for
everyone because
um what you end up doing then is you end
up in my opinion you end up
um kind of pitting people against each
other you know
um trying to trying to get to that level
where I don't have to pay the tax
anymore and and then they vote
um kind of with no skin in the game and
everyone else's taxes continue to go up
and continue to go up and continue to go
up so you'll have senior citizens and
disabled people and and
um other people who who have that low
cap
continuing to vote for increases on
people who don't so I think it's kind of
kind of an All or Nothing kind of thing
but I appreciate the the thought and
question
we are over time on our schedule we've
been at this for a little over an hour I
to continue
to work on this uh we're just going to
be pushing that schedule a little bit uh
so next we have representative Porter
with an additional question and then
representative colleague
thank you Mr chair and I'll be brief I'm
wondering representative Roy I live in a
property poor town
um and I'm wondering so sometimes we
have difficulties uh maintaining levels
of services that make us an attractive
town for people to move to and for
businesses to come to because we are
struggling to keep Services afloat the
school's good without overburdening our
taxpayers but we still do overburden not
taxpayers and I agree with you on that
I'm wondering if this
this Constitutional Amendment were to
pass if it's going to be do you think it
will set up a system of Have and Have
Not towns where towns that are doing
well and can continue to attract people
versus towns like Hillsboro that have a
problem with that
um so I I have I'm sensitive to that
issue because ever since I came to the
legislature last term I've heard that
you know property Rich towns property
poor towns and that's an interesting
debate to have but I feel like it it may
it may actually
him actually help because it gives your
citizens that you know the the ability
to say
okay
we can't afford this so we're going to
vote that down or we actually need that
service it lets them decide what they
can afford and what they can't so for
for someone who's interested in moving
to your town
um it they're not necessarily going to
move in say wow their taxes are going to
be ridiculous because they they don't
have a big base it lets them say well we
can go in there and we can help control
the tax increases
um but but I I think that the the
question of equity among among
properties in towns is is really a
different one this is kind of neutral in
that it's a flat rate across the state
for every citizen to vote or accept or
not
um but I do appreciate that that that
situation thank you
one last question from representative
clay
thank you and and I will try to be brief
as well
um I I started mentioning earlier that
um
municipalities such as Nashua does give
senior citizens exemptions on Veterans
tax credits
disability blind deaf kind of exemption
and tax credits as well so my question
is in all of those cases there's
criteria that they have to meet uh for
instance they have to be over the age of
70 and and we do a graduate and so on
for the senior citizens would this one
percent for senior citizens and
disability have any criteria or you just
proof of age and proof of disability
yeah that that would be uh that would be
it there'd be no other criteria
I think a senior I mean I mean let's be
honest there are some them well-off
senior citizens there's probably some
well-off disabled people but we we can
also probably agree that's not the norm
or the majority so for a senior citizen
on Social Security
um and as we know most companies don't
have pensions anymore a lot of them
that's their only income even though you
have that tax credit where they get you
know 600 or a thousand dollars or
whatever it is off their total bill as
you increase taxes every year and their
income does not increase
that that benefit is great but it
doesn't affect them or help them in the
real world where they're on a fixed
income and their taxes keep increasing
but their revenue doesn't so it kind of
like me saying okay
um representative Klee you owe me 200
but you know what I'll knock a hundred
dollars off but that doesn't do you any
good if you only have fifty dollars so I
I feel like you know I I'm cognizant
that we do have tax breaks and credits
for veterans and senior citizens but as
we keep increasing taxes those benefits
that we offer
um I really have no help once once the
tax rate itself becomes beyond their
ability to pay based on their fixed
income
may I have a follow-up by Mr chair thank
you on
I think thank you um representative Roy
yes in some respects it does but um the
the current tax exemptions
um that I speak of with senior citizens
would be
um set at an income level and um and
their home the value of their home would
that when that count towards that so
that would take into consideration the
um those with the low income that would
lose them
I guess my question was more towards I
have
constituents here who are senior
citizens and own million dollar homes
literally a million dollar homes
um at Value and so on and my concern is
that we would take that million dollar
home and only
um give them the one percent so this
this is a question Mike where were were
you considering those types of things
when you um set this and um
we would that would mean a young family
I guess the the converse of that would
be a young family who doesn't meet those
criterias would now be paying two
percent not necessarily owning a one
million dollar home
sure um let me I'll be happy to answer
that well first of all let's let's be
clear this only addresses increases so
the million dollar uh tax on the million
dollar home is going to be what it is
the increase because they're over that
age would only be one percent the young
family's tax is what it is on their
property and their increase would only
be two percent
um I I feel like the bureaucracy that we
would have to create to vet every single
person as a means test in the Shell game
we'd start playing with money
um and people you know putting their
houses in trusts and put it in their
kids I I think it'd be much easier to
blanket say the increase because
remember the vast vast majority of our
senior citizens are not living in a
million dollar homes many of them are
living in an assisted living
um and and God forbid some of them are
eating cat food because they can't
afford to pay the heat in their house so
I I uh I hate to see them damaged with
the with the uh because of the the Daddy
Warbucks out there who are who managed
a thing
and stuck with us for a little over an
hour and and you've answered every
question that was opposed to you so
again I want to thank you and we're
going to at this point close to hearing
still
would you thank you to everybody on the
committee it was a great discussion
thank you
okay we're going to take a break in a
minute but let me just have a couple of
administrative uh comments to the
community uh
I I handed out a couple of admonishments
during during this past hearing please
no one should take any of that
personally I I was admined several times
last year by last year's chairman uh for
the same issue we have to we have to
make sure that during the hearing
process we are really asking questions
of those that are testifying uh to get a
better understanding of the bill and the
intent of the bill uh any
especially with emotional issues that
come before us it's very easy to
want to get into the
into the arena and Duke it out a little
bit with it with uh with some of the the
folks that are proposing these bills
just the time to do that is the
executive session with each other and so
I would just again uh especially as we
tackle some of the emotional issues that
are going to be coming up in our
calendar and let me tell you that that
it was without it was it was with
purpose that some of our early bills
were not the emotional ones we really
wanted to try to practice our process
and make sure that we we understood how
to use this this Zoom process especially
without the with some of the what I'll
call easier bills or less emotional
bills but we are going to have some
emotional uh bills and accompanying
testimony coming up so I would uh ask
the community to try your hardest that
during the hearing that you've formed
your comments in the form of a question
and uh and let's let's hold off in the
debate if we can have all the debate we
want during the executive session if
it's appropriate at that point
so again please
nobody should take any of my comments
personally it was it wasn't meant that
way uh we we all have to work our issue
of a power process works thirdly uh the
weather in Concord here is deteriorating
uh and I think if you've watched any of
the news today you know that it's going
to continue to deteriorate
so we are uh
we have this Zoom process on the
dialogue process to participate in
meetings I personally would would like
to see more people come in person
personal choice based on your own uh
safety uh
but
those are people who aren't here in
person uh I would like you to consider
your own personal safety in the fact
that if you have a long way to drive
home after we're done today you might
want to think about leaving early and
participating through the zoom process
uh that's that that's fine with me but
also as a reminder we are Administration
works with the zoom process if you leave
after the hearings prior to the
executive session and if you want to you
want to participate in your example on
your car phone on your drive home unless
you are unless your image appears on the
screen in the zoom you can participate
but you can't vote so keep that in mind
if you want to leave a little bit
earlier during the during the hearing
process so that you're available to vote
during the executive section uh keep
that in mind as as you make your
decision but but what is most important
is your personal safety and please don't
risk that just because uh you want to be
here and found here with me so I would
ask you to think about that and make
your own personal decision
okay with that uh we are a little behind
our next our next bill
that we're going to consider is House
Bill 64 and but before we do that I'd
like to take a recess for about five
minutes and and if you have
and I want to make a trip to the the
bathroom or if you want to get the three
uh snack or whatever go right ahead and
we will reconvene at 25 minutes past 10
o'clock
chairman Dolan
hi it's representative van Peterborough
24. uh I just want to give you a heads
up as you think about the the schedule
that I'm the prime sponsor for House
Bill 189 which is the last bill we're
taking up this morning I'm going to
recommend an Ito on that bill because it
turns out that just like my other bill
it turns out it's redundant uh and says
the same thing so as another bill that's
coming before the house so uh if that
relieves your sense of pressure I hope
that's helpful to know so I'm just going
to get up and say we don't need it
because there's another bill coming that
does the same thing
um
and I'm going to recommend an itl thank
you for that heads up that will uh what
we can do is if the committee is so uh
uh fine we can we can detect that one uh
right away right that's what I was
thinking and that would get us maybe get
us back on track
yeah well thank you uh so let's see
where that's for five minutes and we'll
we'll start back up at 25 after the hour
and a reminder to those uh online and in
if you're online feel free to uh to mute
your uh your video if you want to do
okay
I'm gonna have to go uh
foreign
[Music]
true
um
that's correct
60.
trip
okay the amendment
okay that was yesterday yeah
so
and this is
who did the
um
same thing
representative
sure
but I love you can see about the
attention
good morning representative
representative machiore
hi when I look on my screen that shows
pianists and attendees
by my name I have
a blue button that says mute and then a
button that says more correct if I raise
my hand it doesn't show
it used to show when I raised my hands I
didn't used to have mute and more
I so so you still have the raise hand
function down on the bottom of the
screen yes I do but when I hit it it
doesn't
hand
so you're hitting it now right now I
have hit raise hand we can I see that
your hand is raised okay and I used to
be able to see that my hand was raised
but now on my
piano that shows who's there yeah I'm
Blue
and next to me
is a blue button that says mute and
another button that says more what
happens
it says I rename
or I can edit my profile picture
so right that's what it should say
representative power do you have do you
have
um something to add to that that might
be able to help because it it looks all
good on this end I'm going to ask
Christina too
representative Powers hand up yeah I was
just hearing what representative Porter
was saying and so I was investigating so
I could learn as well and I'm seeing the
same that she's um seeing the mute and
then the more blue buttons and when I
press more it's as she reports rename
and edit profile picture
and then when so your hand is raised
right now on on the screen that I can
see Plus on your tile can you see you're
hand raised yes I see a blue hand icon
blue hand icon yeah you you see your
hand raised representative power yes I
do and I see a blue hand icon for you
and as well as for representative van
right I was checking this out too yeah I
can see you and representative van I
cannot see a hand by me
I'd like to have that edit edit uh photo
option because I'd like to to put a
photo there when I'm not there and in
some Zoom meetings I have one that
appears but in the State House zooms
it's just a blank screen so I don't know
how I get that choice
so when when you go to join the meeting
there's
um a dialog box that comes up that says
test audio right have you have you all
done that and then there's other options
like look it has video in other
thank you that clarifies I was wondering
all right
representative Porter I will I will do
what I can
help you out it's it's not a big deal
representative it's just I can't see my
hand raised or lowered so I don't know
if I forgot to lower it and
I don't care how about this yeah leave
it up could you leave your hand up or
can you did you get the message that I
asked you to lower your hand
where would that have shown
I didn't I didn't see
you didn't see it may I also add
something to that so in the participant
white box where it lists all the
participants and we see panelists in
blue and then attendees yep in Gray well
at the bottom of that
um I guess um screen if you will yeah a
sidebar screen down at the bottom you
should see invite mute me and raise
hands so if you toggle raised paint
raise hand then you'll see it change to
lower hands so perhaps representative
Porter although you can't see the blue
hand icon currently you might be able to
discern whether your hand is up or down
based on the the button how it toggles
do you see that on the bottom yes I do
understand that that process it just
requires me to be vigilant in that
little box and it's okay I can do that
but I don't multitask as well as the
younger folks around me do so so
additionally I don't have the specific
answer at this point in time but when
you did set up your Zoom account because
I do see that you have your still
picture yeah
Etc and your name as you like it
displayed there may be some options in
there that need to be um set or unset
okay maybe representative Maggiore or
Christina
knows the answer to that better than I
do at this point
it's just strange because it wasn't like
that when I got on this morning I was
fine and perfect the way everyone else
is this morning it just changed it just
changed it changed within the last half
I really encourage this uh Tech talk
here where uh
and those both who are those who may be
further along in the learning process
are helping
the rest of us so I really do appreciate
that but I'd like to get now back to
work here we're going to take up House
and uh
if you're if you'd like to
unmute your um your video or turn your
video on if you're going to print it off
you can do that now and uh
okay we're going to open the hearing on
which is uh relative to renewable
generation facility property
this is a no
payment and lowest taxes public
listening right we are an acronym
called up pilot
acronym
s for payment
so uh
you hear that it has nothing to do with
Aviation it has to do with the
exactly so uh
we have representative Aaron on the line
we do Mr chair and I've asked
representative Aaron
representative Aaron should be all set
to go
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
to committee members can you hear me
yes
thank you so much and um
I'm happy to be here with you this
morning
uh I bring before you today this bill
which seeks to fix and clarify a problem
within RSA 72 colon 74 payment in lieu
of taxes for renewable generation
facilities
the problem was identified by The
Honorable Jim Grenier of lemster last
year during his auditing duties as Town
Auditor in lemster
The Honorable Jim grineer alerted me
representative Porter and others
regarding an issue with the way the
Department of Revenue was dealing with
renewable energy generating facilities
valuation calculations
for those facilities who have entered
into pilot agreements where their
municipalities
we tried to get this fix in last year
when he found the error but because of
past deadlines and coded complications
regarding work on bills in the Senate it
did not make it through the process
without going into too much detail dra
had been including these facilities into
their Statewide education property tax
calculations
although both RSA 76 colon 8 and RSA
83-ft colon 9 made it clear that they
should be excluded from the education
tax and instead taxed as utilities
including them in swept calculations
resulted in a decrease in State
education Aid to the communities where
the facility is located
which means local property taxpayers saw
their bills their tax bills increased
that is what happened to the lemster
taxpayers when the renewable generation
facility switched to Pilot payments
The Honorable Jim grineer was looking at
adequacy estimates for 2021 last year
for the town of lemster
lemster had recently changed to a pilot
agreement with a local wind farm and he
saw that the Statewide education
property tax increased by 40 percent
and caused a 60 to 70 thousand dollar
decrease in adequacy funding for their
school as a result
he discovered that the wind farm
valuation had not been excluded from the
tax-based valuation as it should have
been
the issue is discussed with dra and
Barbara Reid of the New Hampshire
Municipal Association representative
Marjorie Porter and Lauren Martin of
Avatar and they all determined that the
language in this bill that I'm
presenting needed to be placed in
statute for clarity
so I'm simply making the statutes match
up with each other for Clarity by
submitting the change to RSA 72 colon 74
2 which inserts the Line quote but shall
be excluded from the tax base used to
determine Statewide education property
tax in accordance with RSA 76 colon 8 1A
end quote to make it clear how the tax
calculation is to be calculated in the
case of renewable generation facility
that has a pilot agreement with their
municipality
with this in place dra can correctly
calculate the necessary tax calculations
as the statutes require for these pilot
facilities which impacts adequacy
funding
it is important for the interest of fair
Taxation and the funding of students in
lemster and other towns that are
affected such as places like Groton and
Antrim many of our towns may not have
even noticed the problem and have been
shortchanged on education funding as a
result
so I asked you please to pass this bill
through this committee and I'm happy to
take your questions
and I believe that um uh uh honorable
Jim grineer is also um on the list of
people to testify on this bill
yes we have uh representative Porter on
the list and representative Grenier here
uh on the list as well but uh would you
take a question from representative
manager booty yeah sure
thank you representative uh Aaron my
question is does this apply only to the
commercial or is it to individual
well I believe
um whatever facility is uh has gone into
a pilot agreement
and is a renewable generation facility I
I don't know that it uh distinguishes
between commercial or non-commercial I
would imagine they'd be commercial
anyway
I will hold back thank you
uh representative Porter do you have
some testimony
I do Mr chair and I I thank
representative Aaron she did a wonderful
job explaining what the problem has been
and what the fix is
um when when the legislature established
the ability for renewable generating
facilities to enter into these payment
in lieu of taxes uh situations with
communities they're in um it did create
confusion for the dra and representative
then representative Grenier and I worked
on the bill that supposedly fixed it
evidently we didn't fix it thoroughly
enough for Dra so this bill indeed does
um take care of what the problem is and
it doesn't impact my community of Antrim
because they do have a wind farm and to
answer representative me and japoodi's
question
utility properties are taxed differently
then Residential Properties are so any
utility property is taxed in a different
way than an individual would be to begin
with and this bill specifically states
that renewable energy facilities like
wind farms are utilities and to be taxed
that way and not included in the
Statewide property tax so I you know if
that helps you to understand it any
better and I'll be glad to answer any
so that that clarifies to a great degree
so there's no Baseline as to what
megawatt or kilowatt uh it's just
commercial
it's just utilities
you know
um
yeah
uh
representative Dolan we're having a hard
time hearing you could you adjust your
microphone
not necessarily on your computer but the
yeah
very much better thank you so much
um thank you chairman Dolan
um the first comment is I'm having
trouble hearing you
the audio is non-existent
for me can you hear me now though yes
yes
yep better
good all right thank you chairman Dolan
so um I have a question and I'm not sure
if it's appropriate for for me to to ask
the question at this point in time it's
just a clarification with regard to
um a definition
and the question is it doesn't need to
be answered if it's inappropriate I just
I was having trouble understanding
um what exactly is a payment in lieu of
taxes I don't understand what that is
I will try to explain it it's it's kind
of weedy and I would recommend that you
you do your research you seem to be a
good researcher representative power
um
ah some properties are not taxable the
hospital for example all the state
buildings in in Concord
um the University of New Hampshire those
are all non-taxable properties but many
of them
um voluntarily choose to pay in lieu of
taxes they make a payment to the
communities in which they're housed to
help out with the
um
facility the services that they receive
from the community
um back in I believe it was 2009 or 10
or one of those years
there was a an interest in having more
renewable energy properties developed
within the state and one incentive to
get renewable prop renewable energy
properties
established in the state was to allow
them also to make a payment in lieu of
taxes
um to the towns in which they serve so
instead of having somebody go in and
assess the the value of the property as
they would any other property in the
town the the renewable energy
facility says
we'll pay you this much in taxes over
the next 10 years in order for to be
able to be in your community
um it makes things more Equitable they
thought and it was an encouragement to
get
um renewable energy
developed in the state and so that all
happened prior to the time that I came
into the state house but the problems
with dra because of that needed to be
solved because it did create some
assessment and valuation problems um
County wise and and school-wide which is
why representative Grenier and I filed
the bill back in 2014 to clarify and why
this fix is needed does that answer your
question yes thank you on representative
Porter that that does confirm my
understanding so in summary
um
this the this pilot agreement is is it
is it correct in stating it's a donation
of sorts is there any level or is there
any negotiation or conversation
um had to arrive at a particular dollar
amount yes that happens within the town
itself between the town that's hosting
and the renewable energy facility so I
know that the one in Antrim
um the pilot payment is one of the
higher ones that's that's around because
that was what was negotiated I don't
know about lemster representative Aaron
might know that perfect thank you
representative Porter I appreciate it
let me let me also offer some
explanations and give you some examples
of Pilots to help people understand them
that aren't familiar with them
oftentimes uh
Pilots are done as part of an
intermunicipality agreement as well
because uh one town and one municipality
really can't tax another town but there
may be some impact uh one that I
personally uh worked on
because of the town that I'm from
Londonderry you may not realize but the
Manchester Airport is about 75 percent
contained within the town of London
there and so we've worked out since
since we really can't tax Manchester
property tax wise we have an into we
have an Indian municipality
into municipality agreement that
contains a pilot
with the city of Manchester so that the
airport pays Londonderry uh a certain
amount each year for the impact of the
community
uh another example is uh there is a very
a a
750 megawatt uh Power Plant in the
northern part of London area just south
of the airport
and we've negotiated a pilot with that
power plant
great really for a couple of reasons one
it benefits both entities the uh
the power plant
knows exactly how much they're going to
be paying
uh for several years out and it's a
multi-year agreement so they can they
can plan their future business and the
community knows how much they're going
to be receiving on the revenue side so
the town doesn't have to uh
be confused about how much money they're
going to get in tax revenue the next
year so it helps both the entity and the
community with their planning
in terms of tax payments and tax revenue
so that's another example of pilot
okay uh yes again I just wanted to
correct one thing you said
750 megawatt that's a huge one did you
mean
750 kilowatt no uh this is a this is a
this is a huge power plant this is a 750
megawatt has its own pipeline it has its
own natural gas pipeline that comes up
thank you
uh
um yeah if you go by the Manchester
Airport on the on the South Side you may
see a steam plume uh that emanates from
the plant uh
and that's that's what that that is it's
right right near the uh the yogic
okay is it Mr chair I sorry to interrupt
but I see that representative Aaron's
hand is up and maybe in response to the
question
yes uh we go to representative Aaron but
I also also like after her to go to
representative uh a former
representative Grenier as the uh to
testify as well
yeah I uh Mr chair I just wanted to say
that um for further clarification
regarding pilot uh I believe that uh
Lauren Martin of Avatar may also be
testifying today so on this bill so she
might you might be able to direct that
question to her as well
okay thank you
uh representative Nigeria do we have rep
we have former representative uh Grenier
on the line I do not thank you Mr chair
I do not see representative uh Grenier
on the line by name or or any other way
that I could identify but there are two
people calling in if representative
Grenier is either of the numbers that
end in three four five or six eight one
um and uh and he would raise his hand
then we could recognize him otherwise I
do not see representative Grenier
in
he is okay
681 yes
thank you very much representative
Grenier you uh should be all set you
will not need to raise your hand which
is uh uh which is uh star nine so you'll
need to star six in order to speak
yeah
you are there we go there we
go am I there yes you are
okay um
thank you uh Mr chair and thank you
honorable members of Municipal and
County government for hearing this bill
um
I I do want to make just a couple of
points based on a couple of questions I
work long and hard with representative
Porter on this
um Pilots came in to existence to
encourage the development of these
utilities and they are commercial
utilities they're not something that
goes on at the home
one of the benefits of these two towns
of course is revenue and we say that
towns need to have a commercial building
or an industry to help with their taxes
this was that the other thing that it
does and I think many people fail to
know this is it they generate
6.60 cents per thousand in state revenue
and that's another reason why utilities
are not supposed to be taxed for the
swept tax because it winds up being
double taxation
now I have I found this because
um I don't know why this is sort of
thing I do and and I found it about a
year ago
I I have I think uh a written
document that I sent I I didn't know
that I needed to read through that Mr
chair would you prefer that I just take
questions now or would you like me to
read through that document I I would I
um
so I can't I I can't hear
have you supplied that
yes I sent it a long time ago but maybe
I best just read through it then if it's
not clear that I've sent it so I will do
that
the purpose of this bill is that is that
okay yes it is
okay the
and and
the purpose of this bill is to clarify
language a language issue in RSA 7274
that has led to dra failing to exempt
many utilities renewable energy
facilities from the state education
property tax as a co-sponsor of The
Mending legislation HB 1549 attached I
have those things all together in a
document I know it was never the intent
to eliminate the exemption of these
utilities from the state education
property tax which I'll call swept
henceforth there was there was not
language in that 2014 Bill to eliminate
the exemption as several other statutes
would have needed to be changed it is
important to understand the swept is
used to determine the state adequacy
funds paid to each town the funds are
collected and stay in District
there are some towns that receive no
money because the sweat raises enough
Revenue to provide education to be
determined by the state legislature most
towns do receive some level of fiscal
support in addition to sweat funds which
are entire sweat funds are entirely
local when a town has an increase in
sweat revenues all things being equal
there will be there will be a one for
one reduction in adequacy Grant funds
from the state and thus a decrease in
state tax burden
on the next paragraph I go through a
detailed description using
um the tax warrant for swept for lemster
and their tax rate statement both of
which from dra I don't think I'm going
to read that to you it is available I
did send it but um the the long and
short of it is the way dra is doing this
is costing um lemster 42 882 dollars for
the fiscal year 20. 20. it should be
noted that before lemster entered into a
payment of taxes with the local wind
fund the equalized value of the Wind
Farm was never used to calculate the
swept tax while lemster never really
wanted to enter into a pilot the legal
cost of being pressured to do so and I
understand why the company wanted a
pilot they ultimately did enter into a
pilot in after that point they got less
money than they were getting in taxes
and then dra now was taxing the town in
the um swept tax warrant for the wind
farm and
um how fair is that I mean really so I
hope you will support the bill and fix
this inconsistency regarding the
exception from swept and the subsequent
loss of State adequacy Grant funds for
many towns with renewable energy
facilities and there are going to be a
lot more in the future particularly with
photovoltaic there are some big ones
going up around here these facilities
are a plus for State funds at 660 per
thousand
from the state utility property tax the
present practice of taxing the wind farm
is double State Taxation and
I I would
implore you to not de facto punish the
towns for entering into Pilots but pass
this bill and clarify this in
consistency one other point I want to
make because the question was raised why
would you do a pilot in some towns
lemster had a very good site for a wind
farm
the taxes were reasonably low but have
subsequently gone up towns that have
high tax rates and a good site for any
sort of renewable energy facility are
going to be deprived of that opportunity
unless you can do a pilot the original
wind fund had around a million dollars a
year in taxes just in local County Etc
they couldn't exist that way and
ultimately that those numbers have come
down and there seems to be some
reasonable
future for the relationship between the
town
and the um and the wind farm one other
thing is when this started out and I
don't want to in any way sound negative
to dra what they've had to go through in
dealing with this and coming up with
Fair values and all is almost
incredible maybe it is
so they have had to start with the first
Wind Farm which was lemster and
subsequently we have comparative issues
ETC this is a minor thing that needs
fixing there's a I don't believe anyone
has any malicious intent it's one of
those things where I guess you folks
call unintended consequences
so that's what I have to say about this
I do have that document present I don't
know why everyone didn't get it I know
it did go so maybe someone's got it and
can pass it around yeah so if there are
any questions I'm I'm more than happy to
go on with this although I know you're
okay
testimony
I do not see anyone in attendees Mr
chair who has their hand raised all
right thank you I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 64.
and uh
and move to our next bill
which is house bill 67.
I'll still 67
sign-in sheet
at four supports
nine of clothes and one neutral
and do we have representative Marsh on
the line to testify as the sponsor we do
and he is all set to speak
representative Mark uh thank you Mr
chairman and members of the municipal
and County committee it's a pleasure to
join you again today
for the record I'm representative
William Marsh Carroll County 8
representing Brookfield Wakefield Osby
Effingham moultonborough toughton Berlin
sandwich
despite my mailing address I do not
represent the town of wolfborough in
which the deliberative sessions of the
governor Wentworth Regional School
District are held
and I'm pleased to bring you today House
Bill 67 on behalf of my constituents who
feel their right of redress by bringing
petition warrant articles before the
voters has been compromised by the sb2
process
my constituent Diane Smith who testified
before this committee last year and I
believe will be available to testify
today uh we'll tell you what happened a
year and a half ago when the governor
Wentworth Regional School District and I
do not want this deal or thunder
but very briefly her petition Warren
article was rendered moot by an
amendment at a poorly attended
deliberative session held in Wolfeboro
and hours drive away for some of my
constituents
embodies operating under traditional
rules for RSA 39 3 petition warrant
articles must appear on the warrant
without any change in the intended
effect of the petitioned article
however embodies operating under SP2
citizens do not have this right of
redress a petition Warren article may be
rendered moved by Amendment at a poorly
attended deliberative session which may
be scheduled at a time and place
inconvenient for certain citizens this
is exactly what happened in the governor
Wentworth Regional School District
HB 67 would restore the right of redress
to the citizens in sb2 districts by
requiring both the original and the
amended warrant article to appear on the
ballot if both passed the amended
version would take effect so there would
be no conflict
my constituents ought to be able to
bring their concerns before the voters I
urge you to restore my constituents
right to redress by voting hb67 ought to
pass and I'll be glad to take questions
we have any questions for representative
Marsh before we go on to our next
speaker
thank you for taking my question
representative moss and I miss being on
a Health and Human Services committee
with you uh we miss having you
maybe so my question is how would you
identify the uh amended article from the
uh
uh original article uh when it's in the
warrant
uh I believe that the Selectmen have the
right to uh identify things on the
warrant uh for instance they can also
say whether they recommend or do not
recommend particular warrant articles so
I believe that the local Selectmen would
have the ability to identify it in
whatever way they think is appropriate
for whatever Warren articles might
appear
all we do Mr chair and uh she should be
you may need to uh I did okay there we
go okay all right
um am I on video as well
no you're not no oh that's interesting
okay
um good morning Mr chairman and vice
chairman and committee members I'm Diane
Smith I'm a registered voter and a
taxpayer in Brookfield and I support HB
67.
um and I am reading from the testimony
by the way that I had submitted last
Friday to you but I would like to I
would like to read it to you uh for the
record
in 2019 I submitted two petition Warren
articles to the governor Wentworth
Regional School District the first
petition or warrant articles I had
submitted to the district
Brookfield is the smallest of the six
towns within the school district which
is spread over nearly 300 square miles
these articles one for a tax cap on the
annual increase of the local taxes
supporting the school district in one to
establish an elected budget committee
per RSA 195 colon 12-a
were reviewed at The District's
deliberative session held as usual in
Wolfeboro where roughly 40 percent of
the district voters reside
while representative Marsh mentioned
that it was a lightly attended meeting
it was lightly attended from four voters
outside of the district because it was a
larger than normal attendance and I'd
been going to uh the prior
um
deliberative sessions for the school
district
with a large percentage of the voters
president present excuse me being
current or former School District
employees family members of same or
parents of enrolled children
not surprisingly amendments were offered
to both petition Warren articles and
subsequently accepted the tax Gap
article had one simple amendment to
modify the cap from two percent to two
and a half excuse me to 25
excuse me
thus rendering the warrant article
meaningless
the budget committee article was amended
by wholesale changes so as to make the
budget committee advisory appointed by
the school board and with fewer members
thus nullifying the article's intent to
have an elected body other than the
school board to create the budget which
is what RSA 195
the January February 2013 issue of the
New Hampshire Municipal association's
Town and Country magazine under the
legal q a section offered the following
assessment regarding amendments to warn
articles for sb2 towns and districts and
I quote
one of the obvious consequences of this
system is that it gives opponents of any
issue a strategic advantage
those who want to say no only have to do
it once either by altering the article
at the first session or by voting no at
the second session
those who are in favor of an article on
the other hand must attend both sessions
and say yes twice
the traditionally low attendance at
deliberative sessions create some
additional tension about the
deliberative sessions power to amend
articles end quote
I would also add unlike an urban area
organized under sb2 in large rural sb2
Regional School Districts where the
larger town like Wolfeboro is the Hub
and the location of the annual
deliberatives session often the majority
of Voters live outside of that town and
have greater impediments to
participation in the deliberative
session due to the greater travel
distances and or through inclement
weather
as such there is a much greater risk
that fewer of the district's voter voter
majority will be present at the
deliberative session to address to
address proposed amendments to Warrant
articles
further I would add that petition more
and articles to further disadvantage in
that they must surmount the SP2
institutional opposition as well as risk
amendments to the article which may
render it moot or so Twisted as to
become the opposite of the presented
article's intent in my 2019 experience
District voters recognize both of my
articles had been amended so as to be
moved and neither past
but it is my understanding that it in at
least one other New Hampshire school
district where smaller member towns had
wished to change
the cost allocation formula to be
weighted more heavily to allocation via
equalized valuation
through a petition Warren article
the article was amended to have the
exact opposite effect and was
subsequently adopted to the dismay of
the town's already disadvantaged by the
formula
although a similar sentiment exists in
the smaller towns of my school district
regarding the cost distribution formula
no one dares submit a petition worn
article for fear of a similar reversal
of intent via Amendment from the
majority at the deliberative session
held in Wolfeboro
the current statutes and case law
regarding citizen petition warrant
articles poses notable disadvantage in
disincentive to voter influence on local
government
when I realized the futility of
affecting change in my school district I
stopped all my involvement in advocacy
and I now just pay my taxes in the
current environment institutions win and
democracy loses
I would prefer legislation that
disallows any amendments to Citizens
petition warrant articles
nonetheless I heartily endorse HP 67 as
an excellent compromise that will allow
voters the choice to support either the
original or the amended petition warrant
article I respectfully urge this
committee to support this bill and to
recommend hb67 as ought to pass
can you stay to take a question
yes certainly
thank you Mr chair I do have a question
um
my understanding is and sb2 was passed
before my tenure in the legislature even
though I'm old it's been around for a
while and the reason that it was favored
by communities I understand is because
they felt under the town meeting the old
town meeting
um
Provisions
not everybody was able to vote on the
budget to get to the meeting to vote on
the budget and by establishing an sb2
process this would be brought forth to
all the voters and they could all vote
in the voting booth for the for the
budget
um and in order to do that they set up
this deliberative session where Warren
articles could be proposed and changed
before they were brought to the voters
so it sounds like in your school
district in my school district as well
adopted this sb2 because they felt it
was more beneficial to the voters to be
able to vote in the voting booth for a
budget that was going to change their
taxes
possible in your if
your District to get
and go back to a different method so
that this I mean if you have such a long
drive to get to Wolfeboro and and that
sort of thing it obviously a
disadvantage to you have you considered
um changing the method that the district
uses just curious It's a curious thing
so I I
but can you hear me I can hear you yes
thank you okay thank you um I I I
appreciate your suggestion
um I
given my experience with the school
district and the the
um
the
institutional strength that it
represents uh
and and the the
incredible
um I I don't
as a as a citizen I have absolutely no
influence whatsoever frankly and you
know that given the the ability for any
change
with the school board members uh or the
that represent allegedly represent the
communities that are on the school board
um who have uh I I don't I don't I think
that it's it's not plausible the way
that that the current system works to
affect any change that is my personal
experience I don't have a history of it
operating under any other scenario
um because when I
um for as long as I I've been familiar
with the school district it's been sb2
so I don't know how it would be possible
or to go even go back
okay thank you welcome to uh continue to
listen in on the reading but uh next
we're going to bring up
uh can you hear me
we're right ahead okay thank you Mr
chairman and thank you committee members
Cordell Johnston representing the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and we
are opposed to
House Bill 67
I have sent a letter uh this morning to
the committee explaining in more detail
our concerns with the bill the basic
problem with the bill is that it would
introduce into the town meeting process
something that is really unheard of in
any as far as I know any legislative
body anywhere uh that that once a
emotion has been amended you would then
still vote on the original motion and by
analogy if you think about the New
Hampshire House of Representatives if a
bill is filed and then uh there's a
motion to amend the bill and and that
motion passes
the house then votes on the amended bill
you would never go back and vote on the
original unamended bill that that just
doesn't make sense
um
the the argument here
uh first of all there's a suggestion
that that the process is there's that
there's a big difference between
traditional Town meetings and sb2 town
meetings the only difference is that in
sb2 it's a two-step process
um under RSA 39 3 it is true that
whether it's a traditional meeting town
or an sb2 town a petitioned Warren
article goes on the warrant without any
changes
and in an sb2 town
the the petitioned article as submitted
it goes on the warrant and then at the
deliberative session it can be amended
just as
in a traditional town meeting
it can be amended at the town meeting
so there is no difference there
the the complaint that I'm hearing is
um the wrong people are showing up and
voting at the deliberative session
and
therefore we want the legislature to
essentially uh prevent
um what happens
by a majority vote
if the if the petitioners don't want
their amendments don't want their
article to be amended at the
deliberative session they have a way to
manage that which is by getting the
right people to show up and vote that
that is how the Democratic process works
um
and this seems to be a local problem
that
um that uh people are asking the
legislature to solve essentially they're
not happy with how the process has
worked in their town
the problem is not the process the
problem is
um that some people don't like the
results and unfortunately that's that's
um apart from that
obviously I think the idea of having two
different questions
on the same issue on the on the ballot
that people ultimately vote on is going
to cause significant confusion
you're gonna put the original article
and then the amended article both on the
ballot and ask people to vote to vote on
both of them
that that is really a formula for for
major confusion I've put a couple of
examples in my letter to the committee
um
explaining not only how it could lead to
confusion but how it could lead to
adverse consequences that would be
unacceptable to the original petitioners
so
um
as I say the problem can be solved by
the petitioners getting their people to
go to the deliberative session and uh
and prevent any amendment to their
article
and if they can do that the problem goes
away
I would be happy to answer any questions
thank you we have a hand raised by a
uh thank you Mr chair
uh Mr Johnson I have a question about uh
uh I seem to remember
that uh petition Warren articles well
they are amendable
they cannot be amended to nullify
or uh
uh the original intent is
I don't remember where that is in the uh
the statutes but uh I I seem to remember
that is is that correct
uh that is not exactly correct they what
the statute says is that they cannot be
amended to delete the subject matter
though they they can be amended just as
any worn article could be amended to
change the intent
uh for example at my my hometown meeting
last year which is a traditional town
meeting
there was an article a petitioned
article that says shall the town
continue to allow the use of ATVs on
class six roads
and that was amended or it was attempted
to amend it to say shall the town no
longer allow ATVs on class six roads
completely flipped the intent
that amendment is allowed because it
doesn't it doesn't eliminate the subject
matter
it keeps the same subject matter
but it does change the intent it
oh all right well uh
thank you I would uh I would suggest to
the uh first the sponsor the bill that
uh
they take that tact to change that uh
section of the rsas if they're
um interested in maintaining the uh
intent
then that's the only question I have
from the public
that I I can't see in my screen the
representative Matt Fury our technical
I do not see any of the hands raised
hands raised in the public Mr chair
it was with that being said that I'm
going to close the hearing on House Bill
67.
and move on to house bill 132.
and
House Bill 132
and the sign-in sheets
for a supporter opposition we have 18
supporters four people opposed and three
in neutral
and I also wanted to add that the
representative band wanted to introduce
this bill
so
or I'm sorry I didn't did I get that
wrong
yeah I think so I think that uh the
person who's the Prime sponsor wants to
introduce it if they're here uh I just
want to speak in favor of the bill
that's all I'll make a note for this I
just wanted to speak yeah just a speaker
and and I am speaking in the affirmative
okay Mr chair I have recognized
representative yokella uh to speak okay
uh representative the microphone is
yours welcome
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
distinguished members of the committee
for the record my name is representative
Josh okella from Rockingham uh 33 from
Fremont Danville and Brentwood
I'm here introducing HP
132 relative
to the acreage requirements for
single-family housing
and uh to give a little bit of history
on this I
work or I volunteer as on uh Zoning
Board of adjustment in my town and I
live on uh property that is less than a
quarter acre in a town that now requires
a two acre
uh
minimum lot size for residential housing
and also I have a lot of concern with
um
the cost of housing in New Hampshire
and
I think that one of the significant
um reasons for that cost is
because of some regulations that
um
buildings are in large lots to be
utilized and that my goal is essentially
to to create the opportunity for smaller
um lots and and even smaller houses
where people could be able to afford
them on
just normal normal wages my my home I
bought for
um
for an amount that you know we
would would mean that you would have a
mortgage of less than uh you know a
thousand dollars a month and that is
something that I think is relative
relatively rare because of the
um so many lot sizes are so large that
the the cost of the land and the cost of
that
um house
on that land brings the the mortgages of
and the cost of ownership outside of the
reach of a lot of people
and so that's why I think a lot of
people are you know
especially younger people are finding it
hard to get out of and and start on
their own uh living living with their
their family for longer and longer
um trying to save up to be able to uh
live on their own
and so
one of the ways that I want uh
one of the reasons why I believe that we
are moving towards one and two acre lot
size requirements in towns is especially
in in rural towns is
to not over tax the resources
in the ground
and so there's a lot of concern of you
know over
um
over development making it so aquifers
don't have the resources to to provide
water for all of the people in that area
or too many leech Fields will
um
you know there's a lot of a lot of
requirements for leech fields to have a
decent amount of space and land to be
the liquid that's that's um
put out by those those leech fields
so the original intent was to allow and
actually encourage uh
people to not utilize these
the ground resources in in these areas
and to maybe uh allow people to
build smaller homes and take advantage
of
the opportunity to not utilize the
ground
and as their you know Waste Disposal
system
[Music]
in their area
this would not
um this would allow for people to you
know uh have smaller
lots and maybe have a homeowners
association or town water
as and and Sewer as their method of
servicing those
lots and
the original goal was to also allow for
alternative methods like rain water
collection and great water systems and
stuff like that and in my discussions
with the Department
uh
early earlier today you've seen an email
talking about
um changing this language and that would
essentially eliminate the
the other methods of disposal
and
um I talked with them about this and I'm
actually in agreement that you know it
kind of opens up a can of worms that
that we don't really need to uh discuss
and so an amendment has been drafted
um
to accept their their recommended
language
uh and I hope that uh
the committee will will support the idea
that
you know if the if these properties are
not
utilizing the ground in
such a way that we should be encouraging
that uh not utilizing the ground as
their Waste Disposal Systems and have it
treated in such a way that we have more
control of it in an off-site facility
you know less room for
um you know failure
it's easier to regulate those and
um
manage them
and so I hope that the the committee
will be
uh willing to support this this
legislation and I'm happy to
um take any questions thank you
Kevin yeah
oh I'm sorry uh representative Guthrie
all right thank you for checking my
question and thank you for bringing the
issue uh before the committee uh my only
question would be
uh shouldn't this issue be before the
individual planning board instead of uh
thank you for the question
I think uh that
it could be handled by the by the towns
but I think that
it's important that that the um
legislature start recognizing that there
are
limits to what towns should be able to
require
uh of people's Pro and limiting of their
property rights so I think that you know
if they had a five acre or 100 Acre you
know requirement those I think are
unreasonable and I think that the
legislature should start putting some
guard rails to say what is and is not
reasonable
and I think that
for properties where
they are not utilizing the ground as
their water source and just and uh
sewage Disposal system that it is
unreasonable for the towns to
require
unusually large lot sizes and so this is
uh not only a property rights issue and
saying okay you guys you guys have a
reasonable reason to require two acre
lots when you're going to be using that
as a Waste Disposal system or
um for a well but
there needs to be guidelines and also to
encourage people to
uh not to allow for
uh properties to be
cheaper and so that it's within the
it's it's attainable by people with you
know modest to moderate incomes and not
that home ownership is just for the
wealthy because the the um
zoning board can do or the planning
board or the town can do whatever
and put any hurdles that they so choose
in the way
of of home ownership and Home Building
thank you my question representative
thank you Mr Gibbs representative Melvin
in my community will be quiet to have
1.33
now if you do this
would you be
taxing it differently because the tax on
I I have a half a day
and I my house is on it as well as my
business is on it and I'm just 250 000
to that handmade
reduce
and taxes
and how this is going to affect the
community and around and have smaller
loss
a commitment
[Music]
I'm sorry I had a hard time hearing the
question
but if if I was understanding correctly
I think that that the person request the
questioner
um said a quarter acre but there's a
half acre in the bill
and
um all of the
the lots for tax purposes are based on
the size of the lot and
um
based on how much of value is there if
the the lot are is smaller
there will be a smaller amount for that
given lot but that could mean also that
there are more lots and more houses
in uh you know a given acre so instead
of having one uh
let's say house in on two acres you
would have four houses on two acres and
so instead of the tax revenue coming
from all one person it would be coming
from four people
or four households it and so it
wouldn't necessarily reduce the amount
of taxes that a town receives
if I'm understanding the question
correctly but
it was hard to hear so again correctly
but uh where you have my I've looked at
my property for 52 years
since I was there previously now if this
was enacted and it was in a town that
had
a pound of water account service and it
wants to see I I watched a minimum of
135 000 if you have to pay I don't care
[Music]
but how did this how would this affect
some people
I think the towns would be used in some
sort of Revenue because they're going to
be dropping the water sizes they have to
representative college did you hear the
question
thank you it's it was hard to hear
um the question again sorry for
for that um
it it sounded like the that in the
community that the questioner
was talking about there was a flat fee
per lot
and so if you had more Lots
then you would have more
Revenue
no if you if you have a half an acre a
third of an acre or a quarter of an acre
you're gonna pay
1.33
did you hear that
yeah thank you yes I can hear you much
better
um
so
so you're saying that if you no matter
how how big the lot is that you get a
flat fee and so if you have more Lots
then you would be collecting more money
no
no what I am saying is the lot size that
I have is a half an acre the
requirements in my town for a new lot is
1.33 Acres which is an eight uh an acre
and a third and they have a minimum tax
of 125 000 per house lot
yeah
that's the way and then they evaluate
the house
and that's how they get the tax base
for that piece of property so
wouldn't wouldn't the municipalities be
thank you for the question
no they in your example if they have a
hundred and twenty five thousand and
they have
uh as the minimum amount
that is taxable
than if you had more a lot smaller than
that then they would essentially be
getting more Revenue not less Revenue
or they would have to change their
the way that they set up their taxes
that they're under your current
uh example they would be making more
money that the town would be making more
money not less money so they would have
to adjust their their tax structure for
them to be making less money and that's
thank you for taking my question
absolutely
thank you uh we have
next we have
several hand trays we're going to
why would you want to take the zoning
away from the towns and give it to the
state
all I see is a big mess
and developers coming in instead of
putting 30 houses in and putting 60
houses in
and our school is getting overrun
we have more roads to plow
and the taxes won't make up the
difference because you're putting little
small houses in
you won't collect the taxes that you
could with the two-way code every Town's
different you know we don't have water
and sewer the supply
the land that you're talking about
not here in Raymond anyway
that's my question
thank you for the question
you're not taking away zoning
uh Power completely away from the town
that is not the um
the not the the purpose or even the
language in this bill this would only
set some guidelines for situations where
you are providing well uh water sources
and or off-site water and off-site
septic so in the case that you gave an
example that wouldn't this bill would
not apply to that because they wouldn't
and um to address the the issue of
taking taking the uh the guidelines and
setting up some some guidelines for the
towns to say okay you're allowed to set
a limit but it can't be less than this
that's all we're doing or it can't be
greater than this in this specific
situation where you have Town water and
town sewer or
a community Town water and uh Community
sewer option you would not be able to
acquire greater than a half acre and
that actually will if you have smaller
houses then it's it's uh
harder to have
large families and et cetera et cetera
so that wouldn't necessarily increase
the amount of people in your school
system you might be having uh you know
just starter homes for people that don't
have kids yet or res um Elderly Homes
there's a lot of options there that
wouldn't necessarily increase uh the
burden on the schools and also if you
have more dense population then
uh there's less roadways that you have
to plow because the people are all
congregated in one area
and so I just
um
I think that uh that this option is a
great one that that we should definitely
consider
okay
are you still tell them it's only about
what they can do
you're telling our town
this is the size a lot you can build on
this is what the state's saying so all I
can see is a bunch of lawyers coming in
and saying you've got to run sewer over
here I mean we don't have a lot of town
water time soon and we I'll tell you the
truth we don't have the land
you know where that sewered water is to
build these small houses
and uh I don't think it would be
well we're not forcing the town to build
anything so that's definitely would not
be required by this bill
thank you for the question
yeah I want to remind folks that in
order to help you manage the community I
would ask you to have a follow-up and
ask information to have the follow-up
questions we don't get into a debate
during this particular part of the of
the hearings so next three questions
will come from representative Davis
representative Porter and representative
Mr chair and thank you representative
yokelo for taking my questions
um
question number one is in the in the
wording of this bill
why not just say
that how housing that uses Municipal
Water and Sewer as opposed to
using the negative that does not use a
well
what what can you tell me what the um
yes thank you for the question my the
rationale is to allow for
community
uh well and septic also not just
municipalities if it was run by an HOA
uh where they own some
private well and private sewer company
and they were attached to that and it
would it wouldn't necessarily be
required to be
provided by the town it could be
provided by a private source
except that it says that does not use a
well it doesn't differentiate between
public or privately owned Wells
so how would a planning board
you know
so
the the lot would not use a well
or septic so it so the placement of the
well and septic obviously
um even municipalities are
getting that water from somewhere
and so it would have to
it's a differentiation between on-site
versus uh off-site servicing is the
intent no I do have a follow-up question
thank you for that answer
um Mr chair
thank you
um
at least I did oh yes I do so
um as you may know there is no state law
in New Hampshire governing homeowners
associations
so how how would you set up a privately
owned
system of well or provision of this
these utilities
under the structures of a homeowners
association
for which there is no legislative
oversight
thank you for the question I think it
would just be a contractual one
through
when the
when that development is set up it would
be it in the example of a private
Servicing Company it would be set up
when the
the development actually happens that
these these you know these people and
these homes are going to be uh you know
paying to a homeowners association et
cetera et cetera for the upkeep of that
and
um pay for the off-site disposal and and
Supply it it would be governed by
private contracts not by the government
um saying what those contracts should
look like in the example of a private
homeowners association or whether they
should be continued indefinitely whether
some board of directors of all an HOA
might come in and say we're not going to
do this anymore
there's nothing to stop them from saying
that
thank you for the thank you for the
follow-up it would be required that it
would be indefinite because otherwise
you would you wouldn't be able to grow
right so it would have to be Perpetual
for as long as this lot size is this
size
then unless you merge the Lots
then then you would be having a
different different deed and different
restrictions but
you would have to have it to to be
granted this specific lot size let's say
if you had a a one acre
lot requirement normally and you wanted
to build this development but it would
be half acre
uh Lots
this role it would you would need to set
up a system that guarantees that this
these houses will not be used as Wells
and and not use on-site water sources
and Disposal so it would be need to be
Perpetual not just you know for the
first year and then they put a well on
you know one year later kind of a thing
absolutely okay the question will come
from representative Porter and then
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative um for listening so I'm
trying to get my head around this your
make it so
that lot sizes could not be required to
be half an egg more than half an acre if
the law is serviced by Municipal Water
and Sewer or another source of water and
sewer which is off-site of the of the
housing law is that correct
yes okay and again I have a follow-up Mr
chair please my understanding I live in
the town of Hillsboro I once lived way
outside of town on 50 acres I had my own
well and Sewer
now I live in town on a quarter acre lot
with Town Water and Sewer the um area
around where I live there's some still
open land there but not an awful lot
that would be serviced by the town Water
and Sewer so under this bill
somebody chose to build a house or the
town could not say that you have to have
more than half an acre to put a house on
where the town Water and Sewer is
provided but it would not impact the
people outside of that
area of town Water and Sewer is that
correct
absolutely if if there was no no
off-site
options then then they could require
whatever the zoning or planning board
decide yeah
follow Mr chair I'm sorry
so my understanding of the way things
are in towns around the state although I
might be wrong on this where there is
more Town Water and Sewer provided it's
most likely in the already pretty
densely populated areas of the town uh
rather than in the the boonies where I
used to live
so I I can see an objection to this bill
being that you're going to have the
beautiful Farmland is going to be over
developed but am I right in assuming
this the current situation in towns
would most likely that would be
unrealistic it would just be developing
more into the areas of town that are
already developed
thank you for the question yes I do
agree that in the places that have uh
are serviced by the sewer and septic are
going to be the densely populated parts
of town and it's going to encourage that
and it won't affect the the places that
are open space and not reasonable for
you know to to put that uh sewer line
out you know 10 acres or whatever for
one house kind of a thing so yes it's
going to be thank you thank you Mr chair
Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you uh
representative yokila for taking my
question mine is uh follow-up actually
on representative Porter's questions
um I understand what you're trying to do
to infill Lots make more
um uh taxable Lots so it would raise the
revenues and lessen everybody's tax base
but
it would also require an extension or
additional Water and Sewer services for
the new new homes that would be on those
lots
so my question is
um
those are separate funds so yes your
taxes will go down but your water and
sewer rates may go up
and so my my question is that set off
you know depending on the town it may
uh thank you for the question
um so this this bill and and even in
uh any town is not required to put
the sewer or septic that would be a
separate
uh Warren article or a separate proposal
by the town to say okay we're going to
service this street with Town Water and
Sewer
um and so you know let's vote on that it
wouldn't require any town to say yes to
thank you
absolutely thank you all right our next
question is from representative
trelelevin
hey uh thank you Mr chair thanks for
coming to testify for us today
um I wonder if during your research for
the bill that you discovered how many
municipalities towns cities communities
offer a public water service system
water and sewer system in the state of
New Hampshire we have 234 municipalities
thank you for the question I did not uh
find out all the different
um
municipalities that have
uh sewer and water but I'm happy to to
do that research and get that
information for you thank you
and uh just you know
representative has joined the meeting
and I'd like to recognize him with the
questions
thank you Mr chair but uh my question
was answered by another uh
person
okay
we have a next question from
representative major foodie
thank you Mr chair thank you uh
representative for taking my question
um you bring out a very good point in
terms of uh addressing the housing
crunch crisis in our communities but
also have you considered or looked at
um communities that are self-sustaining
not in New Hampshire but self-sustaining
for infrastructure density and Net Zero
communities how would that impact
or what kind of impact that would have
um I'm not I'm not sure I understand the
question but
um
I will try thank you thank you for for
asking I'm I'm very interested in
alternative ways of living so I do I do
follow
um as much as I can this uh this topic
and
I want to encourage the other
with you know alternative ways of
utilizing land and utilizing resources
and I think that
that this legislation would help
encourage that uh
and especially in the time of you know
people wanting to use less and less
resources that it would encourage that
um and and Foster innovation of how that
that could be
um
attained in in a small area
and I think that it that Innovation is
ongoing as we speak and I think that uh
it will help help you know communities
in a myriad of ways and I would it would
be presumptuous of me to to say all the
ways in which it could be beneficial
so thank you
next we have representative mattiore
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
does your bill
um still provide for the local planning
board I I happen to sit on the planning
board in my town uh still grant them the
authority to set uh setbacks uh
vegetative buffers and all the other
buffers that that exist on a piece of
thank you for the question absolutely
um those those
um safeguards are generally
accounted for when you're going to be uh
setting up these lot size so that there
would be a buildable area but obviously
when you're going to a small area if
you're if you're worried about setbacks
and
um if you have you know uh
water resources on that property that
can limit the buildable area and so this
bill would not not limit those uh
restrictions or the zoning or planning
boards uh ability to to place those
restrictions and safeguards on the land
okay
next we have a representative van to
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
letting me speak to this bill uh I'm
actually grateful to be the second
person because I think there are some
things about this bill that I can help
clear up uh
for example the purpose of this bill is
to address two issues one of them is the
ability to create a smaller house on a
smaller lot in a place that is served by
either Municipal Water and Sewer or some
kind of District water and sewer and
those two things are important because
as we know we have Des regulations about
lot size
for on-site Water and Sewer although I
will tell you that on-site Water and
Sewer on-site water and septic can be
provided safely and effectively on a lot
as small as a quarter acre according to
the Department of Environmental Services
so first I'd like to talk about this for
why this is good for a town this is good
for a town because what it does is
encourage smaller Lots with smaller
frontages so why does that matter
if we're talking about infill which in
large part we are because as
representative Porter pointed out the
primary places that are already served
by water and sewer are of course the
existing Town centers so in lots of
towns even though lots are served by
Town Water and Sewer the minimum lot
size in some zoning districts is an acre
there's no sanitary reason for it to be
an acre it's a Vestige I'm sorry to tell
you of redlining in exclusionary zoning
it makes the Lots unnecessarily
expensive and from the point of view of
the Town it makes the frontages too long
and why does that matter because for
every foot
of paved Road in a New Hampshire town it
costs approximately 4.65 cents per
Center Line foot
every year for annual maintenance that
salt sand plow ditch and mow that's not
Paving that's not repaving that might be
patching a few potholes
so when we have lots which are an acre
then that's we'll call it a forty
thousand foot lock that's a that's a
builder's acre and most of those lots in
those districts also require a hundred
feet of Frontage or even 150 feet of
Frontage so you can do the calculation
as fast as I can for every one of those
lots that has a hundred foot of Frontage
the town is
encumbered to
spend 465 dollars so if you have a house
across the street of course it's half
that but that's still
230 dollars a year to salt sand plow
ditch and mo that foot of that hundred
feet so and if you have 150 feet again
you can do the math so by allowing
smaller Lots on existing streets with
water and sewer we reduce
the per foot cost per house as it were
so for example if I have a lot that is
um it's a it's an acre lot and the house
is placed on the lot in such a way that
I could divide it and maintain the
setbacks as noted by uh representative
Maggiore so if my house is now worth
four hundred thousand dollars and and I
have
um a hundred feet of Frontage costing
the town 230 dollars a year I can divide
that and my house is still worth the
same thing it was before I put another
house on the lot next door to me the new
lot that lot is now paying taxes too and
there has there's more taxable house for
Road Frontage so that's the really
important reason to encourage infill in
this way the other thing that this bill
does
from the point of view of uh
infrastructure is some towns already
have a mechanism to do this it's called
The Open Space residential development
it's allowed under the Innovative land
use law which is I think it's 245 but
I'm not sure about that
so in those open space residential
developments you actually can in the
rural District reduce your lot size you
can't reduce it uh different counts have
different rules about how small those
lots can be but again
if they're served if you had a district
a tract of land and you wanted to put a
pocket neighborhood or a cluster
development on it and you were going to
provide District Water and Sewer you
could build smaller you could have
smaller Lots less Frontage less expense
to build the road for those people
making those houses cost less
which brings me to the other side of the
equation so that's the municipal side so
on the other side you have the Builder's
side
for a builder the raw land cost is about
20 percent of the final sale price of a
house so when you require a bigger lot
than is necessary for sanitary reasons
or you know whatever reasons you have
if you require every time you make a lot
bigger you make the house more expensive
and since you can't
if you spend a hundred thousand dollars
on a lot you're not gonna put a two
hundred thousand dollar house on that
lot because it doesn't pencil it doesn't
make sense financially
So when you buy a lot that costs a lot
of money you have to put an expensive
house on it and it's a big house and we
know that demographically across the
United States only about 20 percent of
all households are households that have
school-aged children in them
so I think the concern that oh my gosh
we're going to get all these children in
our schools if we allow smaller houses
and smaller house Lots is Miss is a
miscomprehension of what's actually
likely to happen we figure
um in my business that if you build uh
20 20 small houses you might get four
kids out of those 20 small houses you're
not going to get
uh you're not going to get 40 kids you
know you're just not that's not how the
demographics work anymore and in New
Hampshire as in most places in the
United States we have a mismatch between
our housing stock and what people want
um people want
um both people as old as me and people
as young as my kids and some of the
people in between would like to live
within what my daughter refers to as
stumble home from the bar distance
so that means we need but we're not
building any more of that often because
our zoning codes make it really hard to
do that this is a step
it's a little step by the way it's a
little step in the direction
of making it possible to do infill in an
existing town and these are not little
lots a half an acre is a big lot and I
did a survey in the town I live in
um a number of years ago and determined
that in the historic area of
Peterborough the average lot size was
about
it was about a sixth of an acre
um so that's pretty small
um
but you know people like Peterborough
it's pretty cute
um so this is a thing that would allow
us to do some infill
and it's also a thing that by doing
infill we increase the tax base and in
the rural District if a developer wanted
to do a cluster and spend less on
infrastructure therefore making those
houses less expensive they could use
this to do that I will tell you however
that doing uh
uh group District Water and Sewer is
District sewer is pretty easy to do
District water is more complicated so my
my sense is and my observation is that
it is unlikely that we're going to get a
giant bunch of cluster developments
in the rural district with District
water because it's a much more
complicated Affair and having said all
that I'm happy to take questions
thank you and let me uh let me speak
about the testimony you deserved
facing some frustration are people who
are confused about my earlier
admonishment
uh representative van
contacted me prior to the meeting and
asked if she could have permission to
speak uh to offer testimony as a
very much like a co-sponsor so that's
why if you were thinking earlier about
what well is she going to get to a
question no she asked for permission to
speak like a co-sponsor so that's why
you heard her offer testimony in that
light so at this point I'll offer it to
the committee if you want to ask
representative van to have questions
about the emergency
just getting testimony
okay
yes thank you for the informations
towards fabulous uh and thank you for
taking my question my question is
something like the first one I asked
prior and that was don't you think or do
you think that this kind of uh situation
uh it is a zoning problem and there's
more uh belongs in a at the local level
instead of at the state level
I'm actually
I have that question because uh in my in
my daily life I'm a certified urban
planner I'm certified by the American
Planning Association and by the Congress
for the new urbanism and this is what I
think about all the time and what we've
seen across the United States is that
when we leave decisions like this
in the hands of individual neighborhoods
and individual jurisdictions there is no
incentive to make changes that will
allow for more housing why would you
because you think well this might be
moderately inconvenient for me or maybe
I won't like it so why should I do this
if the town next door to me is not doing
it why should I make my town different
um in a way that you know makes me
nervous when other towns don't have to
so what we have seen is that when
particularly about issues like this
um it's it's actually better to do it on
a bigger space you don't have to do it
at the state level in New Hampshire we
have to because we're at Dylan's rule
state other places have done it on the
county level but it turns out that it's
more it's fairer more transparent and
more accessible if you do it over a
bigger area so that's why I advocate for
doing it
in a bigger area rather than at the
local level
thank you for your answer very
of manduri
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative van for taking my
question if I heard you correctly
um one of if I heard you correctly what
I heard was that this type of
development is not going to drive
school-age kids from moving into these
kind of communities and going to school
so my question is
who's going to be moving in well
according to the demographic of
information that's available to all of
us right now about 20 percent of all
households are households that have
school-aged children so it's all the
rest of them also maybe some with
school-aged children but not by any
means all of them some of them are
younger people that want to live as I
said within stumble home to the bar
distance some of them are older people
who want to live
uh within walking distance of the corner
store so that every trip doesn't require
a car particularly as they get older and
maybe don't drive anymore so there are
all of the people that we have are all
of the spectrum
are Desiring these places and that's
actually one of the reasons that housing
costs are going up is the thing that
more people want we're not building
enough of we haven't built enough of it
in a long time
let me let me say that we are
significantly behind schedule we will be
going to House Bill 154 next
uh and then
I'll spell 189 so those of you who may
be online are a few uh waiting for those
bills please be patient we will get to
them and we have some more testimony to
to here and those that I'm gonna
try to highlight your testimony and be
as brief as you can without without
losing the points that you really need
to make
so next I'd like to call on
Representatives McWilliams who's also a
Mr chairman
chairman I just
I just uh representative McWilliams and
I'm not sure that she is available
um is that right representative majority
thank you representative van I I was
just going to ask I don't see her named
here but names can come up a little bit
differently but I do not see her name
here well I just got a text from her
let her speak okay great I'll let her
know thanks next we'll uh we'll go to uh
nhma Cordell Johnson and then after him
we'll go to the commission of BTS
umridge
thank you Mr chairman again Cordell
Johnston representative mature Municipal
Association and we are very much opposed
to House Bill 132 uh just to be clear we
have nothing against
um half acre zoning we think it's a good
idea a small lot zoning more dense
development is a good idea but towns are
not all the same
uh towns are towns vary dramatically in
New Hampshire and that's why we have 200
plus zoning ordinances not a single for
the entire State
we are very concerned Whenever there is
an effort to mandate
uh zoning requirements I hate to use
terms like slippery slope but if uh if
today it's lot size limits tomorrow it's
youth restrictions and house sizes and
and who knows what else
um
there are
there are other efforts on going uh to
encourage denser and more affordable
housing
um and uh I think through education and
incentives similar to what are in uh I
think it's House Bill 586
um there's there's a long long way to go
uh and New Hampshire is not by any means
the only state that has a housing
shortage or an affordable housing
shortage
um
and and so you know there's no Silver
Bullet that's going to solve this
problem and I don't think I don't think
this is going to do it uh the uh both of
the sponsors I think talked about why
this is good for towns
um and I agree that smaller lock zoning
is good for towns but if it's good for
towns
um
the state shouldn't have to require the
towns to do it
uh if the towns understand that it's
good for them they'll do it on their own
um
there's a discussion about how
um smaller lot zoning will lead to
smaller houses
that that may or may not be true I think
you've probably all seen areas around uh
Lake uh Lake Winnipesaukee other lakes
in the state and other areas where
um
developers are buying small houses on
small Lots tearing them down and
building
mcmansions that take up pretty much the
entire size of the lot so I I think
um you should be careful about assuming
that this is going to
result in a significant change in
Behavior but basically our concern is
that zoning it is and has always been a
man a matter for local control
and once we start going down this road
it's a question of where we stopped with
with State mandates we already have the
requirement that towns allow uh
Workforce housing we have a requirement
that they allow manufactured housing
requirement that they allow accessory
dwelling units
um
and none of those have solved the
affordable housing issue I doubt very
much that one more Statewide mandate
will solve it so we
believe that this should best be left to
the discretion of municipalities to
figure it out on their own and do the
best that they can
thank you and I'd be happy to try to
answer any questions
thank you enough questions at this time
to thank you for your testimony Mr
Johnson I'm going to go to now
yes hi um good afternoon chairman Dolan
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Philip Trowbridge I'm
the manager of the land resource
management program at DES representing
the commissioner Robert Scott thank you
for the opportunity to testify on House
Bill 132
um in the interest of time I'll go very
quickly the department has reviewed the
bill and takes no position on it with
regard to lot sizes
however should the committee choose to
move forward we've suggested some
language uh some suggested edits to the
language regarding septic tanks in order
to bring it into
compliance or to match what's in our
regulations and statutes
so I believe representative yukela has
drafted an amendment to accept our
recommended language we had a short
conversation with him earlier today
so uh briefly you have the letter in
front of you
um the the language that refers to uh
dispensing of liquid from a Blackwater
septic tank right into the ground of the
lot
um does not is not defined in our
regulations or our statutes and we've
suggested just to use language that says
does not use a subsurface sewage system
sewage Disposal system which does
um so it again we take no position on
the
um the lot size issue
but we would suggest this different
language if you move forward with the
bill
thank you thank you are there any
questions for Des or nhma
seeing that is do we have uh Mr Firth in
queue a member of the public
hello this is uh doctor there we go
can you hear me
yes
thank you so much for your time uh chair
Dolan Vice chairpy Monte and members of
the committee thank you for inviting me
to comment I study land use regulation
and housing markets as co-director of
the urbanity project the mercatus center
at George Mason University uh I study
minimum lot sizes especially
um you have my my written remarks and
I'll try to go through those quickly so
as to respect everyone's time
um to get a sense of the reach of this
bill
I audited zoning Water and Sewer maps of
six New Hampshire municipalities Dover
Exeter Keene Manchester Meredith and
Nashua in all six municipalities I found
areas that are served by Municipal Water
and Sewer but that are zoned for an acre
or more
however all of those areas were modest
in size often consisting of one or two
subdivisions and curiously most house
Lots in those districts were already a
half acre or less
so I therefore believe that hb132 would
have modest and Scattered effects
nevertheless those effects would largely
be positive for New Hampshire residents
governments and those seeking to for
conserve forest and agricultural land
I'll give you four quick reasons uh
first as uh as has been discussed
smaller Lots promote affordability they
require less land
um and they tend to have smaller homes
on them there are exceptions
smaller Lots use fewer Municipal
resources uh representative van gave a
tremendous example of this and uh you
know in most utility districts you're
billed by the gallon used say rather
than the foot of pipe but the foot of
pipe still costs to install and maintain
and replace at the end of its useful one
um when you do infill development using
the same water mains
typically everyone's taxes and utility
rates will fall because there are more
users paying for the same amount of
infrastructure and then everyone pays
for their own gallons kilowatt hours Etc
uh the third reason that smaller lots
are good is that they have less impact
on the environment they can serve forest
and agricultural land by using lesson
and finally and I think most importantly
lower minimum lot sizes expand private
property rights there are legitimate
limits on those but in general a just
and limited government
will come up with a very good and clear
reasons to limit private property rights
before doing so the default should be to
allow people to use their land as they
want in this case most of the public
interest runs in favor of smaller laws
not in favor of larger ones and
therefore I don't see this as a case
where there's a good reason to limit
those private populations
finally there's an issue of fairness
as I noted most of the lots that would
be affected by this bill are already a
half acre or small
so this bill would extend or write some
Property Owners already enjoy the right
to have a house on a half acre to
neighbors of theirs on similarly
situated land
um and you know when I speak about
deregulation I often get someone
objecting that uh changing their
neighbor's zoning violates their
property rights
um I think that's backwards if you want
to control your neighbor's property you
can buy it and then it's your property
right but until then it's theirs
um
and uh yeah so I believe New Hampshire
Property Owners current and future would
benefit from less regulation of minimum
lot sizes more young families would be
able to start at home future taxes and
utility rates would be lower be more
woods and farms and property rights will
be stronger and fairer thank you for
your time everybody happy to answer any
questions either now or by email you can
contact
thank you we've got considerable
testimony in this bill and it's been
very educational so thank you I don't
have any questions cued up from the
committee
so I thank you from those those who have
offered testimony and have uh endured
the uh the calendar stretch here so uh
at this point I'm going to close the
next we're going to move to
which is
dealing with Community revitalization to
and do we have a representative grassy
yes and there we go
ahead
you need to unmute them
I have requested that he unmute
Mr chairman yes go right ahead yes
um my name is representative Chuck
brassy from Stratford 11.
I'm I'm here as a prime as a co-sponsor
of hb154
and I just did a little bit of History
I was a city councilman here in
Rochester New Hampshire
uh for about 25 years served on the
planning board here in Rochester for
about 12 years
also was the town planner in the towns
of Alton
Raymond and stratum for a total of
almost 20 years
um
I I look at this bill as being part of a
toolbox
that communities can use
to develop their communities uh here in
Rochester
we have a uh We've we've used these
tools in the past
particularly when you take a look at
community revitalization tax relief
incentives we have 97e which this bill
address this is and we also have Tif
districts which we've used here in the
city of Rochester
I set in negotiations with a company
saffron Aerospace
saffron ge when we brought them here to
Rochester and we were competing with the
state of North Carolina at the time
by the utilization of the shift District
we were able to win over saffron and
bring them to the city of Rochester at
the same time we also brought the
corporate headquarters for Albany
International to the city of Rochester
and we have the very successful Ridge
commercial District in the northern part
of our city this is just one of the
tools we used
right now we're looking at bringing
1979e and utilizing for the downtown
Redevelopment of a former theater in the
downtown that's been sitting vacant for
oh God I would say 30 plus years
that no one's in 40 years that no one's
been able to do anything with
what this bill does what 154 does is it
expands the ability to use to use tax
financing incentives or tax incentives
in the local community for redevelopment
of these structures for housing
something that downtown districts
significantly need
it also allows us to
um
expand the amount of people the number
of people that are eligible
these uh for these benefits as well with
these these housing units it helps us we
did one project the first project we did
when I was on the city council here in
Rochester I'm not currently a council
member but one of the first projects we
did was a very unique building right on
the edge of our downtown district
uh it's basically an old castle it had
set vacant for a number of years we're
able to provide tax incentives to allow
them to redevelop and redevelop it as a
restaurant and events center
uh and and unfortunately due to the
pandemic it's been a little bit of a
struggle recently but prior to that it
was a relatively uh successful uh
facility
this is a tool it's something that is
optional it's enabling legislation it's
not required of any Community to do that
but as someone who has worked at the
local level for 25 plus years I find the
more tools we have in our box the more
competitive we can be we can be when
we're attracting out of state
the investors in our communities and
also the more competitive and the more
Innovative we can be when we're dealing
with local small businesses who want to
do something new and Innovative in our
communities
I'll be happy to attempt to answer any
questions
um
and uh that's it thank you
thank you very much for representative
Chris
guys chairman
Mr Vice chair you have uh representative
manager putty and representative van in
that order with their hands up I just
wanted to let the vice chair know that
the other Prime sponsor of this bill is
now on the call and I don't know whether
you want to do something whether you
want to recognize him at some point
that's all
give me give me the easy questions
Mr chair I just need to let you know
that
um the love of my life has reappeared in
the 1950s for his lunch he'll be gone in
half an hour thank you
already
I think he recognized representative
Manju Puti did I hear that correctly oh
sorry I didn't hear my name so I was
waiting to be recognized thank you Mr
chair thank you representative gasly for
taking my question
um does this also include the historic
tax credits that is available both
Federal as well as very underutilized in
our state to revitalize or renovate
historic buildings old dilapidated or
falling apart buildings in the middle of
our main street or in our cities and
towns
it's it certainly does and I think that
what you're looking at here is that as I
said before the more tools we have in
our bag
to be able to help the revitalization of
downtown or to attract
people from out of our community to
invest in our communities the better it
is I've said in these negotiations
anytime you can pull you know pull
something out of your hat to put onto
the table it's a benefit
uh it's optional you you use it as a
negotiating tool and it works uh I found
that they've been we've been very
successful particularly here in
Rochester and we've got a long long way
to go but and and we've we're trying to
do more for our downtown districts and
one of the things and is certainly
providing more quality housing in your
downtowns uh we've had too much of the
apartment structures with the uh studio
apartments that that tend to be very run
down and this is something which has
allowed us to to attract investment to
try to rehabilitate and Revitalize some
of these downtown buildings
follow-up Mr chair so would this also
this gives another tool like the
um opportunity Zone historic tax credits
and uh historic renovation
um uh opportunities so this very well
says about it how what is the time frame
you're looking at that's the big
incentive to bring new investors into
our state not the current one that hold
on to it but I I will tell you that the
work that we did with bringing saffron
into the state of New Hampshire uh took
us uh more well over a year uh sometimes
and I think it was closer to two years
that we were in negotiations with them
and then there was probably negotiations
prior to getting into the city council
level uh but I know I sit in the in the
room uh which were highly confidential
negotiations and we were we were really
um being very competitive with the state
of North Carolina and their Raleigh
Durham area particularly uh that's
everyone almost went in that direction
because of the technology I mean we work
with every partner that we had in the
state of New Hampshire and what it was
it was the Tiff District because it was
structure that needed to be put in place
that made it possible to get them for
them to get real access as well as to
get airport Access through skyhaven
airport that brought them to the city of
Rochester and that's just an example of
one of the tools we had this is another
tool with 79 years
and purpose and a different reason but
it's still something
I want to use could be incur
makeable for them to use it it's not
going to be right for every Community it
looks right for us and I would hope that
thank you uh we have a question from
representative Clayton
uh thank you Mr chairman and um thank
you representative grass if you take my
question
um my question is is there a time limit
it once they get this um
the the tax credit or incentive is there
a time limit that they have to keep the
particular percentage of these homes
affordable
um I noticed that it talked about at
least 50 percent of units be affordable
at least 40 percent of units affordable
with low income and so on
um does it have to remain that way
forever I know in some instances they
say they put a five-year moratorium on
it or is this um
in perpetuity uh no it and unfortunately
it's not in perpetuity uh that's
something that I've certainly looked at
in the past as a town planner uh we had
some instances where we wanted to take a
look at how long he's in for and a lot
of times that's a negotiated agreement
you have with developers to how long
they will stay in perpetuity uh we
certainly need to take a look at
something at the state level to see how
we're going to do that uh to make them
be affordable in perpetuity but as far
as I'm aware
I may be wrong
um I've only been back this will be my
third term back in the house I've served
eight terms now in the house uh but um I
don't think there's any any rsas that
require would require a that it be in
perpetuity but it's something we should
definitely look at
thank you very much for taking my
question we appreciate that
Mr chair I I apologize for butting in
but the prime sponsor for this bill
representative Casey Connolly is on the
call and he's jumping up and down to uh
to speak and I'm wondering if you might
want to recognize him yeah
representative Conley go right ahead
thank you uh Mr chairman committee
members and thank you uh representative
majority for uh for accurately depicting
what's going on here
um
um yes Casey Conley state representative
from Dover
um I will try not to repeat what has
already been said about HP 154
um so as we've heard it would it would
broaden the existing statute around
Community Development incentives uh
under RSA 79e and the goal here is to
promote new housing construction
particularly affordable housing
something we desperately need here in
New Hampshire
um for those on committee who don't know
uh the existing 79e statute already let
cities and towns offer time limited and
targeted property tax incentives
uh for development
within downtowns within Village centers
and as representative
um manipuri was discussing four historic
Redevelopment that's already within the
law
um so the bill before you does a few
things to broaden that uh first um it
would let municipalities use these
incentives anywhere within their
Municipal boundary not just the Village
Center who are tied to a historic
Redevelopment
um and the second thing is it would
extend the maximum term of the tax
incentive to 10 years
um up from the current nine which is
sort of the Max and that's with some
um some escalating uh years for doing
certain things but the the current
Statute in general is five-year limit
um
and then the way you would get these uh
these broader incentives is if you
maintain a third of the the units uh in
any new development for moderate income
residents that's the key piece here
so again some context you know we know
RSA 79e works we just heard that from
the representative from Rochester we've
seen it used well in Dover
uh and just this week our city council
will hear another 79 E project to rehab
a vacant courthouse uh into something
you know vibrant and and great and
revenue producing for our downtown
um
and just to highlight a couple of the
the sort of limitations in the current
law again it's constrained to town and
Village centers
um that's where development costs are
highest and that's also where there's
the highest potential for market rate
rents so not not necessarily a place
where you'd see affordable housing
um
so you know again this was enabling
legislation as has been noted many times
municipalities could decide for
themselves where they wanted to use
these Provisions how they wanted to use
these provisions and again the key being
that they could do it anywhere so they
could do it in places where development
costs are much lower and that would
hopefully translate into lower rental
rates
um committee members who were on the
committee last term will remember this
bill has come before you before uh and
it passed the committee with an
amendment then passed the house with
broad bipartisan support went to Ways
and Means as a second committee where it
received a 20 to zero recommendation
um so in closing I'll just reiterate
enabling legislation doesn't require
anyone to do anything
designed to attract new market rate
housing new affordable housing things we
really need probably in every community
in our state and it's designed in a way
that lets municipalities
uh decide for themselves where and under
what terms they wish to use it and in
partnership with private developers so
with that I'll uh take any questions
uh we have
from representative major putio
Mr chair
um my question to you thank you
representative Conley for taking my
question uh how does this fit in with
the last uh term I had introduced the
pace legislation to enhance or bring in
new investors how does this kind of work
that into
um
attracting new uh investors as well as
restoring and redeveloping old buildings
thank you representative so
this is a tool that our cities and towns
certainly know about uh developers
definitely know about it
um so it would come down to I think the
circumstances to determine whether a
particular project fits within the
guidelines of the existing law
again the proposal before you would
expand that and create a whole bunch of
new scenarios that would work and that's
the idea
um so referring to Historic properties
again that's already part of the bill or
that's already part of the law so that
wouldn't change
um
at all uh and and as far as attracting
developers um
I would hope that this would further uh
entice developers to invest in our
communities
thank you and uh we have a question from
representative power
thank you chairman Dolan and thank you
representative Conley I apologize I was
taking copious notes and I missed the
part you had explained the history of a
prior
um bill that was similar to this and you
noted that it passed this um committee
that you're in front of was that with an
amendment
representative yes it uh it left the
committee with Amendment
um and the language is still in the bill
from that amendment that adds some
definitions around
um affordability it's updating a
different section of law around
um standards for uh low income and that
kind of thing and there's others who I
believe are planning to testify who can
better speak to that because that was
not an amendment I brought forward but
that uh yes that is the the background
on this bill
and then follow up
go ahead so and then you explain that it
passed the house with bipartisan support
and I missed the part of what happened
to the bill ultimately where did it die
oh yes I did neglect to tell you that so
it it ran into the covid related uh
shutdown of legislative activity last
year
okay well thank you uh next uh testimony
would be offered by Mr Ben Frost from
good afternoon Mr chairman and thank you
for the opportunity to testify uh my
name is Ben Frost I'm the managing
director of policy and public affairs
for the New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority and I'm here to express New
Hampshire housing's strong support for
this legislation and our gratitude to
representative Conley for introducing it
again
um this bill really should be seen as
two separate independent but
interrelated sections and they are
sections one and uh one one two and then
the second section is is three so two
two uh independent Parts the first uh
part of this is the the part that IT
addresses RSA 79e and
um this this statute has been around for
a number of years it was uh enacted by
the legislature in 2006 uh and I I can
tell you that as of uh now as of 2020 at
least 59 communities in New Hampshire
are utilizing RSA 79e as a tax incentive
for different kinds of development it's
enormously flexible I was one of a small
team back in 2005 that drafted the
original legislation that became RSA 790
and we we envisioned it as a as a tool
that municipalities might use we try to
make it flexible and it is very very
flexible and I'm just kind of shocked
and amazed to see how successful it's
been so I'm really gratified this
morning I was driving to to work and I
was listening to exchange and Laura
Canary was interviewing three Mayors in
in New Hampshire mayor Craig from
Manchester mayor Hansel from Keene and
mayor McCarley from Rochester and both
Mayors Hansel and McCarley talked about
RSA 79e as an important strategy for
their communities uh as it's one of the
few tax incentives that municipalities
have to attract new new investment so
representative mandaputi has talked
about how do we attract investment to
New Hampshire this is one thing that the
municipalities can use to Market
themselves to investors from from Beyond
New Hampshire as well as within New
Hampshire
it's really powerful and is highly
discretionary so it's a purely enabling
legislation municipalities can do it if
they want to they don't have to if they
don't want to uh and the the change to
the statute that representative Conley
is proposing in House Bill 154 is a very
welcome change uh RSA 79e was originally
conceived of as a tool to help with the
Redevelopment of downtown areas and it
does that and it still does that but
what it doesn't do right now and what
house bill 154 would allow
municipalities to use it to do is to do
new housing development in areas where
the municipality wants to do have have
new Housing Development done so it's
totally up to the municipality to decide
where it wants to do this and what the
time period is
um the the tax relief that would be
offered under one houseboat 154 under
RSA 79e would be for up to 10 years so
it is discretionary for the men
municipality to decide how long to make
that up to 10 years
um and there are there's a reference in
um
in section two of the bill to the
questions of affordability and so it
says shall be designated for uh
households uh with an income no no less
than a third of the housing units in one
of these developments in a Housing
Opportunity Zone would be uh allocated
for people making up to 80 of the median
income for the area or that would meet
the income targeting standards nrsa 204
C 54 comma four
now that statute and that's where we get
to the the second principal part of this
legislation uh is um the the state's
affordable housing fund it is the
state's affordable housing trust fund uh
administered by New Hampshire Housing
and it has existing income targeting in
it that was designed by the legislature
back in in 1988 and it was designed well
at that time to meet the the needs of
programs at that time but those needs
have changed so new new federal programs
have evolved over that time that have
different income targeting standards so
we last year approached representative
Conley and asked him if he'd be willing
to integrate this amendment into his
legislation and he agreed to do that and
so that's what you see before you know
it's it's
changing the or refining the income
targeting in the affordable housing fund
to match up with uh Federal programs and
then it ties back to RSA 79e in the
amendment that representative Conley has
proposed so that a developer will have
some flexibility in what sort of income
targeting should be done in that
development uh if a municipality chooses
to employ this measure I'd be happy to
take any questions and thank you for
listening to me this morning or this
afternoon
thank you yes that schedule is
stretching a bit I'd like to recognize
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Frost
for your testimony my question is you
talk about RSA 73e how does this enable
or enhance RSA 5380e
I'm not familiar with the statute that
you're referring to RSA 53 yeah that is
the pace District
case legislation it's kind of very the
mushy area for New Hampshire I I had
forgotten the um the statutory reference
but I was actually involved in the
drafting of that some years ago
um with representative Beatrice pastor
of Hanover uh so uh they're they're
complementary they're overlapping they
don't necessarily
um rely on each other so you could have
a a an RSA 79e Housing Opportunity Zone
that would overlap with a a pace
District but my recollection is that
under current New Hampshire law uh pace
is limited to commercial
so not residential and and
representative Conley's Amendment uh
proposed amendment to RSA 79e in House
Bill 154 is just dealing with
residential development uh so there
could be some overlap but they they
thank you
okay good thank you any further
questions for Mr Frost
uh seeing none uh do we have anybody
from the public would like to speak to
this
Mr chair I've noticed a hand raise since
the beginning of this hearing from Doug
Marino I don't see him on the list but
I'm happy to recognize him if you're
willing go ahead Mr Marino you're uh
you're welcome to offer some comments or
actually ask a question if you welcome
people who testify
uh thank you so much Mr chairman
um my name is Doug Marino I uh work for
an organization called 603 forward we
are um an advocacy organization whose
aim is to help make New Hampshire a
better and more Equitable place for
young people to come and live and uh and
start families
um it's uh and I'm expressing uh my
support for House Bill uh 154 as well as
the house bill 189.
um it's critically important for the
legislature to take steps that will help
attract and retain young people here in
New Hampshire
um we're in the midst of an affordable
housing crisis that requires our
immediate attention these bills will
help incentivize local communities to
invest in affordable housing projects
and we'll open up opportunities for
Working Families to pursue affordable
housing options New Hampshire's housing
crisis is a five alarm fire that
threatens our economic future I've
personally witnessed many friends from
high school and college leave our state
and take their talents elsewhere May any
of them would love to start a family
here in New Hampshire but they can't
afford it
the lack of affordable housing options
in our state has created an economy that
is unsustainable but these bills are
steps in the right direction that will
help make New Hampshire a more viable
option for young families so I
appreciate you for considering them and
I strongly urge the committee to give
them a positive recommendation thank you
so much for your time Mr chairman and
thank you to the members of the
committee Mr Marino did you have a
written testimony to submit
uh yes Mr chairman I'll send that along
to the committee
um as soon as I I hop off here
thank you so much thank you Mr chair a
request from me about the blue sheet
yes the sushi
and Mr chair I will let you know there
is one other hand raised from attendees
from a Kathy Staub
yes uh go right ahead well welcome to
hear your your comment
thank you very much Mr chairman can you
hear me yeah go right ahead okay thank
you my name is Kathy Staub and I'm part
of the Manchester housing Alliance which
is a group of tenants and ordinary folks
in our city who are concerned about the
lack of safe and affordable housing in
Manchester and I'm here to support house
bill 154. in particular I support the
provisions that at least one third of
any development in these Housing
Opportunity zones
um who receive this benefit
um the affordable units according to the
New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
the average rent for two bedroom in
Manchester is one thousand four hundred
and eighty three dollars a month
Manchester has a lot of restaurants
retail and cultural amenities which
means there are a lot of low-wage
workers that are critical to making our
city run
for example Manchester area has 9 300
Food Service workers with a median wage
of twelve dollars an hour at that add to
that essential workers like cashiers
home health aides and janitors and you
can see that many people struggle with
the cost of local rents
every week we hear about seniors and
disabled people being evicted to make
way for renovations and higher rents
recently a development that received
such a tax credit
um as the 79e
began offering units for rent at 1400 to
2 000 a month which is Outreach for many
working people in our community when
wealthy developers receive tax
deferments the roads still need to be
maintained the trash still needs to be
picked up and our teachers police
officers and firefighters still need to
be paid as a homeowner and a taxpayer I
don't mind making up the difference to
help people of modest means which is the
change that this legislation will help
to ensure so I really appreciate that I
believe that when public resources are
used everyone should have the
opportunity to benefit including people
of modest means
well this is a good incentive I think
we're going to need to be vigilant
because um I have
um concerns that maybe there are areas
um in Manchester that are a hundred
percent affordable housing which is not
in very good condition but it's still
affordable that might be displaced and
instead replaced with areas where only
one third of the housing is Affordable
but I think that's on the Manchester uh
housing Alliance to be vigilant on that
and and keep our local Municipal uh
decision makers
um
from making that kind of a decision so I
I fully supported this bill
um and I thank you for allowing me to
testify
thank you for your testimony and your
interest in this
uh seeing no further questions or a
testimony uh and two we're going to
conclude the public Nearing on the bill
on tonight and move on to HB 189.
which is our last bill public hearing
now this this is a bill with a sponsor
has indicated to me that
the bill with uh
that she would like to withdraw the bill
is uh and she can explain why but we
don't have a real clean mechanism to
just withdraw our bill the technique
would be to itl the bill and executive
session so representative van would you
uh Enlighten us
yeah I'm happy to talk about this this
is another case where I was doing the
belt and suspenders thing but it turns
out that we don't actually need the
suspenders uh this bill is redundant to
a bill that we'll hear later in the
session H Bill 341 and since it's
redundant and says the same thing uh I
think we should just itl it and take up
341 when it rolls around on the calendar
and save us all some time and trouble
and it is unless there's objection in
the committee we'll do just that is
are seeing that uh we're going to
conclude the public hearing on HP 189
and move immediately to
Executive session on that bill and then
we will take a recess
so we are now in executive session to
consider HP 189 and other than that I
would ask for a motion IPL
Mr chairman I move that the committee
itl house bill 189.
for a second I second
seeing the uh that's the clerk to take a
role
let me just get this here and and while
the clerk is getting ready for the
standard ban I would ask you if you
could write up the
yes and I owe you one for the other one
we itl'd I'll do that this afternoon and
you know
189.
yes
representative Tripp
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative
representative power yes
representative Trey 11 yes
representative Gilman
yes
representative majority
representative mangaputi yes
representative fan
yes
representative clay
representative Gallagher
yes
representative Dolan yes
and one more try for a representative
and Mr secretary and Mr chair I'm
looking on both the list of panelists
excuse me list of panelists and list of
attendees and I do not see
representative air
um I can certainly send representative
air an invite to the uh to the zoom just
in case something might have happened
and I'll do that now
thank you and we'll we'll wait to see if
you responds that invite but unless I
see his smiling face that we're not
there are no proxy votes in executive
session
and while uh that's that's happening
with representative managiuri I would
ask if the
ranking member has any announcement that
she'd like to make to her caucus for a
Caucus meeting prior to the executive
session
we beat you to it Mr chair we met at 8
30 this morning we're all set thank you
the
Republicans will be meeting in room 300a
down the hall uh
and then there is a zoom invite
but if you're going to meet in person
you know you don't need to be able to
it's just everyone
yeah
question Mr chair is the zoom going to
change are we stay on this to continue
on the zoom
going to defer to representative manager
but I think we're going to stay right
online we are
um so as as the chair has stated thank
you Mr chair uh as the chair has stated
before the mics will still remain hot so
so mute yourself uh go off screen but
the recording does not stop if we stop
the recording the live stream we we cut
the meeting in its entirety so we don't
want to do that so the meeting will
continue to run and oh I really should
have put up a little uh note there that
says we're at lunch so I'll see if I can
do that and let the public know that we
are we are at lunch until what time Mr
chair
uh until two o'clock two o'clock so I'll
put up a little note there
okay
and and Mr chair
whether it's snowing pretty hard down in
Nashua I don't know how it is keep an
yeah
yeah I moved that we uh I think we've
waited long enough for the response from
that okay I agree I I don't think we
need emotion I think
I think we've waited long enough so and
I don't see anything
so what is our vote at this point uh 18
to zero on the Ito without objection I
will uh submit this to the consent
calendar for House Bill 189 and that
yes uh
for Representatives uh Tripp McBride
and power I want to make sure that you
all have your Zoom invite for this
special meeting at 1 30.
I wish where should I check Mr chairman
checking your email
I got so many emails hey give me a
second
excuse me if I hit the leave button I
have to rejoin when I come back is that
right that's correct okay so I should
not do that what
legislation do you have a legislative
email inbox no I don't if I do I don't
use it I use my Comcast you make product
I don't have one as far as I know and I
let me do this uh
we're troubleshooting some Republican
business right now so but let me uh let
uh and it's adjourn it uh actually we'll
recess it until two o'clock and uh and
the demo the Democrats that are online
representative Dylan is it okay for me
to mute the room can someone unmute
before you continue
I'm not sure that we have that expertise
to know how to do that
okay
okay just wanted to double check
Mr chair I can walk you through that if
you if you just go over to the big TV
directly across from you and use the
mouse to go down to the lower left hand
side all you have to do is hit mute
okay
I'll mute it for you now but you'll have
to unmute before we start that way you
can have your lunch in peace all right
but but those those uh members who are
in the room you can you can stay here
and we normally don't allow food in
these girls but even the current
circumstances you can keep your lunch
right here if you have it with you the
camp unfortunately the cafeteria is
closed
remember the mics are hot so if you'd
rather discuss issues I would suggest
even though there's going to be uh help
I I trust her like my sister but uh I
still
[Laughter]
Mr chairman where would I want to look
for that email who's it coming from
are you getting an extra copy being sent
to you right now from uh Tony fiamonte
okay I'll look for that name thank you
could you please send me one too because
uh I don't have anything from uh uh
I forgot the name of the lady already
would have would have been the house
Republican office at Senate Big Stone
what was his name yeah Megan Megan Stone
Megan Stone
Diane power did you have a question yes
um representative Dolan I am I am in
receipt of that email may I go to lunch
yes I did get it all right go right
and 1 30.
so we're sending uh
there is a thermostat over here I don't
all right
my hands are freezing
are you cold no I just uh
difficulty hearing a lot of people in
okay
yes is um chairman Dolan still available
is he in the room he is in the room he
is yes I see him I think I see him yeah
there he is
this I have a question for him
so
um representative Dolan he won't hear
you because I muted the room okay
maybe I should just call him can you let
him know I'll call him on the phone
I would just text him that's what I
would do that you're I would say that
so
I I just want to um I just realized
um so you said that
the this meeting was going to re you
know stay put you weren't it wasn't
going to end just the audio would be
shut off
right and I'm I'm staying on this
meeting and it will be muted and I'll
shut the video off so I guess the
question is for the Republican caucus
I need to go on to another device in
another location well that's one one way
to do it or you can you can leave this
meeting
and go on to the other meeting and then
rejoin this meeting later okay do you
have a recommendation
I would leave the meeting and then and
then rejoin it too okay that's fine
thank you for clarifying that I
appreciate it
okay can I get every pride is he there
yeah I got I got just got the email I
foreign
okay
oh
Christina can you hear me
I sure can
should uh thank you for uh helping out
today should I alert the uh people in
the room if there are any to unmute the
uh unmute the computer in there or can
[Music]
I'll go back on mute so nobody has to
listen to my droning
and thanks for all your help by the way
again
of course anytime I appreciate your help
too sure oh oh can I can I throw one
other thing at you sure
um and I don't know where to where to
send this
um but it seems like or actually ask the
question it seems like people who sign
up the day of to speak
um are having trouble either it's not
registering it's I could certainly
understand where it wouldn't be put on
the on the late lists is that something
to follow up with or is you know is that
something the system can improve upon or
or be improved upon or just tell folks
hey you got to sign up before you know
five minutes before the meeting
or should we talk about that offline oh
no it's okay if people are signing up
um after eight o'clock
um it's not you're just not gonna get
the the accurate record and then to
raise their hand so even if they're
registering it's just it's virtually
impossible uh for me to go and get a new
testimony list for every hearing Before
the bill okay and communicate it in a in
a not so in a not awkward way to the
chair there are people who want to
testify so um the expectation is if they
do sign up ahead of time and I'm able to
look I'll usually you know text the
chair but um it's just sort of up to the
chair to say you know are there any
other members of the public that want to
speak and that's their opportunity
okay great
I'll send something off to uh to uh to
chair Dolan and let him know to remind
folks that they need to uh in order to
show the accurate reflection of what's
on the blue sheet to make sure that
people sign up before 8 A.M on the day
of the meeting schedule as a good just
reminder for what we have to do okay
now I'll shut up representative Gilman
oh you are back are you back from your
sure
okay
um I sent around to those folks
that I send things to to the Dems of
Twitter thing
that I just saw that cracked me up
and it's about a zoom meeting and a cat
so you might want to check your email
and uh and and if you can deal with
Twitter through your email it just
I did not mean it as an insult to you I
was I was praising you for your ability
to do research on these things I've been
impressed with how much knowledge you're
bringing forward to us so I wasn't
trying to be mean or anything when I
said that to you representative Porter
that's how I took it that you were
complimenting me okay thank you thank
you
I I just want to say I am also very
impressed with you representative powers
to kind of focus on
you know I'm a newbie on this committee
so asking the questions that's all I've
always learned right we just have a
committee I have been on to learn and
ask the questions and I'm really
impressed thank you thank you
representative man japoodi I observe
everyone here and I'm learning from
everyone
[Music]
it's one nice thing about this committee
it's always been
for the most part very non-partisan
because the issues that we deal with are
pretty Universal
things that towns and cities have to
deal with um so it's nice it's nice to
get to know somebody
in a nice way rather than a
confrontational wearing
that's true the only reason I
I always thought one of the wisest
things we did in the towns anyway was to
not identify the political party of the
people who were running for local
offices because it really when you're in
the local office and you have that
experience it's a universal kind of
thing and there's no I don't think
there's a Democratic or a republican
viewpoint on
on certain issues that we all face as
Town officers
and I think we bring that neutrality
with us into this committee
and I think I think that's a really good
thing personally
I was just going to make that comment
when I served on the school board and
until I ran for State Rep I was an
independent you know and no
party affiliation or Dr and r so it was
um
I think governing has to be it like that
can you hear me
oh
representative Dylan you'll just have to
go to the computer
um near the TV and click on mute ah
perfect okay we just did it we have a
new technical expert
uh in this Epic
oh am I going to have to share my my
considerable salary for doing this with
that person we already took it away from
me Jim
laughs
happy to give it back with all the pay
and compensation that comes with it
we already knew he was the king
my crown I was gonna ask for his crown
and scepter yes absolutely don't get us
started now
representative Dolan I don't know if you
can hear me can you
um we have two hands up in the um
from the attendees one from
representative Edwards uh saying he
signed up to speak a little while ago
for two minutes and representative Sykes
uh we're going into executive session
though now right right there's no public
testimony there's no public testimony
I'll just ask for clarity from them and
to follow up with you if that's okay
about their uh about whatever testimony
they wanted to provide what can you hear
me yes
what what they're welcome to do is that
they have some testimony on bills that
we've heard they're welcome to send them
to the committee and we'll have the uh
the clerk put it in our file folder okay
I'll make sure to send that off
the
so everybody knows that we go to
Executive session
so the committee only and only in rare
s
try it again
is that better
yes seems yeah
okay
all right so uh we're going to open the
executive session
for the municipal and County government
committee
today
and we have several bills to consider
the first one
let me ask a ranking member do you you
had expressed an interest in the order
of bills for one particular Bill earlier
in the week uh do you still have that or
does it make anything no no we're all
set now thank you Mr chair okay
uh any does anybody else I'd like to try
to be as accommodating as possible as
anybody else
uh gonna have to leave the meeting early
and wants to vote on a bill before they
leave and it will I'll rearrange the
schedule so that we can do that for you
not seeing any requests
they're having this virtual option will
tie me down here and I will participate
till the end thank you
so let's consider uh build house bill 79
first
that was the one about the town Health
officers
working with DHHS at the stage yes uh
everybody yeah I would I would move that
ought to pass
okay we have a motion about to pass is
there a second
I'll second that okay representative
lisella seconds it
is there any discussion
all right I just want to make a comment
it seems like
a good opportunity the pandemic has
really given us an opportunity to be
better prepared
in what we learned in the last one year
I think uh I commend the sponsors and
all the people that I work together
to in a bipartisan way to put this
together
uh remind me was was that uh
representative McBride that made the
motion yes it was representative McBride
yes
[Music]
okay so we have an ought to pass motion
with a second
no amendments and uh I asked the clerk
representative Piemonte
yes
look folks yes
representative Tripp yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative Rosales yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin no
representative Porter
yes
okay
representative majority
oh boy yes there I am
yes
representative Gallagher
we're having a hard time hearing you
representative I think um representative
yeah
right here
while you look the cleric or the chair
uh the clerk um what was the name before
the chair
representative here
oh okay I'm sorry we couldn't hear that
and I wanted to make sure nobody got
left out
I'm sorry I will say I have we have not
I have not received a response from
representative air to the invitation to
rejoin the meeting and I see no messages
here
votes yes
passes are 17-1 and will that go on the
calendar and without objection I'll uh
remember the rules for the consent
calendar it has to be unanimous or not
have one more than one negative vote
so if it was 162
I would not be able to put it
or if any of you object to it being
there
uh disqualified as well
Mr chair I have a question isn't it the
practice if it has a FN attached to it
it cannot go on
and calendar is that the practice are
now
uh if it has FN it just means that it
no you I'm no representative mandaputi
actually is correct we're not supposed
to put any any bills on the consent
calendar that are F and bills even if we
have a unanimous vote
I that's the rule that I used to have
anyway we used to have then I wasn't
aware
hahaha
everybody
representative Dolan you did not serve
any bill off the consent calendar if it
had an FN on it and yeah berate us for
minutes about it so that's that was my
experience my first term representative
having trouble hearing you you're going
in and out
go snuggle up to your microphone please
okay if I get much closer I'm going to
uh okay representative to 11 I couldn't
[Music]
okay
uh
the next bill we're going to consider is
uh House Bill 88
.
chair I moved that HB 88 ought to pass
is there a second
no second
representative
I can't hear you
um just just a curiosity question how do
we usually reconcile the blue she
responses so far we've been good like
there's more support
yeah there's no reconciliation it's just
uh it's just input for the committee to
to consider when you're making you vote
okay thank you
yeah
okay
can you hear me now
yep yes okay I've noticed they took out
on the commission and I just felt that
is that does anybody have any
uh already on that because
experience
on it
I just wondering why they would lose
I'm not sure I I heard urge a whole
question representative but my
understanding is that there was just one
person who was making the appointments
for the police commission
and they wanted to have the city council
take that job back so that the city
council was making the appointments
not just one individual making all three
appointments
ideas
I'm sorry I just didn't hear you the
rest of what you said
um I'm just asking why they didn't keep
the managing involved in any
I'm having a hard time hearing
I'm chairman Dolan you can't go look at
the microphone if you look away because
yours is not attached to your head then
there you go
[Music]
right now
try it now are you better oh way better
yeah there you go I will now mute myself
so that I don't blurt anything else
[Music]
I'll take all the help I can get
okay uh Mr clerk please take a roll okay
it's uh ought to pass on HP 88.
representative yes
good folks yes
representative Tripp
yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative lasalles yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative here
okay
representative power yes
yes thank you
uh representative Trey
11.
you got it let's representative uh
Gilman yes
representative Missouri
yes
representative stavis yes
representative megapudi yes
yes
okay representative clay
representative Gallagher
yes
and chairman Dolan yes
passes are 18-0 would you like another
consent calendar well this is not an FN
Bill I know that's what I see you know
yes without objection we'll place this
and the next bill to take up is House
Bill 183 which is
commonly known as the lemonade stand
bill
uh
so I'm going to make a motion
for an amendment
like I told you about
2021-0092h as in Hotel
this amendment is a simple event changes
the terms from Lemonade Stand to uh soft
drink stand
so that uh
well let's leave it at that if you want
to have discussion we can
so I want to make a motion
um to amend the bill as I just indicated
Mr chairman
thank you
any discussion on the amendment
yes
um Mr chair thank you I think the
amendment makes the bill better so I'm
going to be supporting it
you just have a process question so
first we're going to vote on the
amendment and then we vote on the
amended bill
what about Girl Scouts
no there'll be no Girl Scouts I'm
serious
and it seems to single out one type of
activity
out of a range of activities that are
similar in nature
and carves out an exception for those
for that one activity it just it seems
it seems frivolous to me yes in the fact
that it could be said this is a
a solution looking for a problem uh I
don't have any uh
any indication that law enforcement has
been
uh I've seen any of our young people
around this issue but this is this is a
this is what it is uh I've amended it to
try to clean it up a bit from just the
lemonade stand because
they want to sell water or Coke or
Kool-Aid or whatever that fixes that
part but I I understand I think we would
uh if you want to uh
submit a bill for bake sales for our
next session I think that we could do
that as well
representative
comment yeah I just want to say this is
uh basically for the kids
um you know I I don't know
see you guys except
the Miss representative Guthrie is older
than I but
um when I was a kid they we just have a
lemonade stand five cents a cup or
whatever the thing was and uh that's all
this is for it isn't for anything else
it's giving them some recognition I know
the Boy Scouts can do it the Girl Scouts
can do it
there's uh I haven't seen and I'm
nothing against your big sales
representative Stuyvesant but I haven't
so uh maybe it could be with another
bill for next year and I would support
that I'll let you know right now
all right and I'll uh I'll use the front
the French pronunciation uh for
uh I think this bill is frivolous I
think it's a waste of our time it was a
waste of our time last year it's a waste
of our time this year to understand what
representative Porter said Thoth drinks
his broader than just lemonade stands
but you know this is trying to take us
back to an Era that we're not in anymore
stop wasting my time I'll be quoting new
things
okay
representative clay
thank you very much
um I I have similar
um uh comments as as the last speaker
um I I fear the unintended consequences
I agree that this is for the children
um I also agree with the with Mr
chairman which you had mentioned a
solution in search of a problem
from what I've been able to investigate
and so on I haven't seen anything that's
happened throughout our country in
almost 10 years I am afraid that what
it'll do is it'll give license to those
who want to put children in front of a
um a professional lemonade stand and
they're running it and then all the
money becomes non-taxable and while I
agree that we think well it'll only be
50 cents or 25 cents that would be yes
for children's Lemonade Stand but if
they put it at a race or in front of a
ballpark or something to that nature we
really could be going down a slippery
slope
um and then people are going to turn
around and say well but what is this
what are that you know whether it's the
bake sales okay so the children that
made brownies to go with it and
I I guess I'm just I'm starting to get a
little concerned about it and while I'm
still new on this committee I think I
have to vote against this one slippery
slope be greased by Lemonade hold on a
second administratively we are now
presented with a motion for the
amendment when we're not we're not
talking about the bill as amended yet
which is just for the amendment to
change lemonade to soft drinks at this
point so if those of you have your hands
up if you still want to talk just about
the amendment then uh we'll go for that
so uh representative Porter
I just want to urge my colleagues here
that the amendment makes the bill better
and if the bill is to pass without the
amendment
that's doing I think harm so that's why
I would urge us to vote for the
amendment and then deal with the bill
separately as amended
thank you uh representative Moody I will
hold my comment for uh octopus amended
okay
uh seeing no other hands up well we have
a motion for an amendment with a second
and that's the the clerk to take the
role okay this is going to be roll-off
yes
clerk votes yes
representative Tripp yes
representative lasalles yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
yes
representative
representative majority yes
representative Davis yeah
representative megapody yes
representative van yes
representative clay yes
representative Gallagher
yes
motion passes 18-0 I like to make a
motion the
OTP
us Bill 183 as amended
exactly Mr chairman
was that representative McBride yes Mr
chairman
uh and asked the clerk is there any
discussion as amended yes president yes
um I think this is a bell that is
looking uh solution looking for a
problem so I really cannot support it
and uh even though it uh your Amendment
did make the bill a little better it's
still you know my neighborhood kids sell
lemonade and cookies in their front yard
so now I have to go say no you can't
sell the cookies you can only sell the
lemonade or water so it just does not
make sense so I will be voting again
representative Porter
thank you Mr chair
beside from the fact that with some of
us think it's a frivolous bill I think
it was uh Cordell Johnston's testimony
that kind of struck me
if a kid puts up his lemonade stand in a
dangerous place
this bill would prevent
the authorities from interfering with
him which means they would they can't go
and tell them to please move or if they
did they would be violating
this this that we're passing I think
it's a concern it's not just we don't
want the selling the lemonade but if
they're in a dangerous situation there's
no adult supervision and the police
officer's hands are tied because you
can't go and help to move the child to a
safer place that's a concern so just to
throw that out there
thank you representative mantiardi
thank you Mr chair
um one of the members of uh former
Selectmen here in Northampton and a
member of the planning board said says
continues to say so often after 15 years
we don't understand the consequences of
our actions until they're tested I just
have to feel I I just feel and I've seen
it time and time again the minute we put
something down on paper people test the
limits I and I'll repeat then
unfortunately what I've heard I just
think we're creating a solution for a
problem that doesn't exist but then
maybe May suddenly bubble up to the
surface with all due respect to the
positive things that this may may
prevent or give us a way out of so
unfortunately I'll be voting against
okay
so
you lowered your own hand it's so
technically smart
okay so we have a emotion
to OTP as amended for House Bill 183 I
asked the clerk to take the role
KGB 183 you ought to pass uh
representative Piemonte yes as amended
right right yes amended uh click folks
yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative lasalles yes
instead of McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative
no
representative majority
yeah
Representatives Davis no
representative van
no
representative clay
representative Gallagher
no
a motion fails uh eight to ten what was
it
eight to ten eight to ten okay the
motion failed so I'd be looking for a
new motion at this point
Mr chair I move HB 183 in expedient to
motion
excuse me someone said as amended it's
not as amended when it's an Ito motion
because we amended the bill that just
failed now we're back to the original
bill
we lose Representatives
he's uh he's getting his paperwork
together oh okay ah we can't see him so
we don't know what he's doing we thought
representative van lemonade oh right I
forgot
[Laughter]
I miss seeing representative McDonald to
my left
he listens to my left pass in the blue
emotion is
um
representative
oh right representative Guthrie
yes
representative lasalles
no
representative McBride
oh
one more time please
no
representative
yes
representative Gilman
representative majority yes
Representatives Davis yes
representative magaputi yes
representative van yes
representative clay
yes
representative Gallagher
and representative
motion passes 11 to 7.
okay thank you
all right let's move on to
House Bill 332
332 as a reminder was
the developments of regional impacts by
and we have a uh
a motion by representative McBride yes
yes sir I've moved that out to pass
second
okay any discussion
oh
representative Mr chair we said my
recollection was there a discussion
I didn't hear what you said the question
was was there discussion about retaining
it
I don't have that in my notes does
anybody else have a record a
recollection of retaining this bill in
the early discussion
yeah
I guess the answer is no
representative Porter
I do remember and I thank you Mr chair I
do remember in our discussions however
that the municipal Association uh had a
came out against it and they wanted to
just work with the um with the sponsor
of the bill to fix the language that
they had concerns about
um and so I'm wondering if that
Amendment came through
um
it would concern me if the if the
municipal Association had a concern and
hasn't been addressed
okay now I'm not aware of an amendment
coming through on on 332.
thank you that was the thing that was
stuck in my head there was something to
yeah that was uh represent uh Mr Gray
was the representative from nhma that
Mr chair I'm sorry to jump in and uh
there is an email that we got yesterday
about 3 32.
that's right
but it doesn't it it doesn't seem to say
that
an amendment is going to be forthcoming
now my reading of that excuse me sorry
my reading of that email was that in
fact the sponsor believed that the bill
as written really did answer the
question brought up by the person who
um the new the municipal Association
person right
so I think their plan is that we should
vote on the bill as proposed
um so just uh
um lend or con contribute to what the
discussion here my notes say that natch
graze from the New Hampshire Municipal
Association
um opposed the bill as written and he
offered to work with the sponsor but
he's willing to do
um whatever the sponsor wants to do as
far as an amendment so that's what my
notes say
thank you representative uh Porter but
the sponsor
refuse the offer yes I believe that's
correct I mean that's how I read the
email so
I guess that's my concern if I if I had
her if we had heard from the municipal
Association that they had conferred with
the sponsor and agreed with the sponsor
that they had Mis misunderstood I would
feel a little more comfortable but that
that's not how I read the email
representative yeah that my my reading
was also similar there is the prime
sponsor
was offered uh collaboration from nhma
and that was not received so to me it
uh is that representative McBride yeah
I'm sorry Mr chairman I spoke without
planning director specifically about
this bill and he specifically told me he
had no problems at all with it
okay representative maggiori
oh thank you I was just going to
reiterate what everybody what
everybody's saying and by quoting what's
in the email it says I feel that the
requested changes to the bill are
addressing a different intent that what
was then what is in this bill as
submitted that seems an indication that
we won't be receiving an amendment thank
you we have a we have a motion and a
second that's the clerk to take the role
on House Bill 332.
okay HP 332 uh motion not to pass
um yes
Court votes yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative lasalles yes
representative McBride yes
representative air
representative power yes
I'm gonna have to vote no I just wish
that I had heard back from the
Municipal Association something
different
yeah
no
representative majority
no for the same reasons that I heard
from representative Porter
Representatives Davis
no for the same reasons
representative mangaputi no for the same
reason
representative Klee
no
um
Mr chair when when a motion is tied like
and that means that the floor the house
is full body makes the determination
um we could have another vote on a
different motion maybe and it might
change the vote you are correct
what is the feeling of the uh of the
community do you want to
try a different motion or do you want to
you could do a motion to ICL you could
do a motion to retain
should we not could we not retain in
some fashion
and seek more clarity from nhma
we can but the bill won't come back up
until uh the next year
Mr chair could we ask Christina perhaps
she has a knowledge of procedure that we
don't have maybe oh you said it
correctly
um if you can either take a motion
um another motion
um if you'd like
are you asking about retaining what was
your question the question is can we
take another motion if if you're saying
we can then that might be a wise way to
go or put it up for the house to vote
okay that's my opinion I'm sorry
yeah representative Guthrie uh if we do
take no action just refer to our whole
body without a recommendation between
now and when it comes before the house
we may have something right now more
yeah
and explain that
and let the House vote yeah that's true
retain and that's right I believe that
um if if we keep the nine to nine vote
and refer it to the house without a
recommendation
uh we can
during the debate
in the we can talk talk to it but we
can't change the vote I understand that
but the house the house
right so it'll give them an opportunity
concern seems like the concern of most
of the members that voted no was that
they were not clear about what was
coming from a municipal government uh
Municipal Association and I think that
that way we could uh at least not moves
the bill if in fact this does do what I
think it does uh it's a housekeeping
bill it happens to be one of the close
points is my senator
so Mr chair I do have a question or uh
Christina
could we recess this executive session
on this bill
and bring it back the next time we meet
and maybe someone reach out and see
what's happening from the municipal
I don't believe we can because we've
already taken a vote
okay I don't know that's why I asked
you choose to keep it without a
recommendation you'll just have to write
two reports one for the motion or one
for writing those up
yeah
representative you want to write up why
we shouldn't uh no no no I'm just trying
to say you know considering that we are
in the middle of a pandemic and we are
trying to conserve the time and effort
that we put in as a full member and
in a session I'm thinking you know if we
retain and work it at least it's much
clearer the reason I voted no was it it
didn't feel complete we hadn't done it
one of my options is to retain
if we take a new vote we can take a new
vote to itl or a vote to retain yeah
that was I was thinking uh take a new
vote that's my thing
uh representative clay you have a
recommendation
I'm not so sure about a recommendation
in um maybe I'm just not quite
understanding is retain the only option
is there a way of just um
I know we've taken a vote in it and it's
tied so is itl or retained the only
option that we have is there a way of
um
I I don't want to use the word table but
I guess that is kind of what I am
basically hold it not for next year but
hold it for as as representative Porter
said maybe our next meeting or something
to that nature that's just I want to
know that ability
then a motion to table would not be in
order
yes are either itl retain or no
recommendation
was that Christina yes can you repeat
that so your options are itl retain or
representative McDonald
I'll do a motion to itl
well before I accept that motion I have
some additional discussion that I think
I want to take first uh
no I was just going to say send it on
with no recommendation okay uh
representative Maggiore
and I was just going to say at this
point it's our bill so I I don't want
this to sound disrespectful but
um but the sponsor now his intent of the
bill may be different but we have been
presented with an opportunity to
actually take his bill have it comport
with the law with the help of of nhma so
either that be done by I I would say if
we can do that through retaining it or
through an amendment on the floor I
would be good that way but otherwise we
we've shown the unwillingness from the
sponsor to to change it because he has a
different direction for the bill so uh
right I think I just see an opportunity
Echoes of Representative Guthrie's uh
a recommendation which is to send it
without send it to the floor nine to
nine and then it can be resolved on the
floor either with an amendment there or
with an explanation
uh representative van yeah I was just
going to say that I I do think that what
we should do is send it without a
recommendation and if we determine after
a conversation with nhma that a floor
amendment is in order file a floor
Amendment
um and deal with it that way I I don't
think I think that's our best choice at
this point
okay do you have one more comment
I I'm just trying to think about the
time and effort that's needed in in a
full session and we don't even know
where we're going to meet and that kind
of stuff so it's just in the interest of
time and efficiency I feel like uh this
can wait till next time or that's just
my my personal
reporter
if we send it without a motion without a
recommendation and come to the house
with a floor Amendment then whoever is
presenting first which I think the first
speaker is the negative you know the itl
speaker would be the first speaker
um could say we have an amendment and
now we're we're recommending that this
pass with this amendment or not I think
it's an option I think it's a wise
option
it looks like there's no additional
comments so I'm inclined to send this
forward with a nine to nine vote and if
I look for two volunteers one two uh to
write up a report
that it should be passed and one right
upper report it should be itl you have
volunteers
wants to volunteer that it should be itl
take it Mr chair but I've already got
three or four that I've got to do so
somebody else want to take it
I'm sure if I'm going to be there at the
full session or not so I don't want to
volunteer I would otherwise
I can take this one okay and do I have a
volunteer to write up this is the king
yeah OTP side of it
can I ask if you've representative
McBride
I'm sorry Mr chairman yeah I'm not sure
whether I'll be there either or not but
I'll I'll put something together sure
okay yeah it's just something to go into
the uh the house calendar okay
and just submit that to the clerk
okay thank you
Mr chair can I ask a follow-up oh I'm
uh my question is
um
then if
what is going to be the process then for
looking for that Amendment
should that just be a decision among
those who voted against that that we'll
just assign somebody to go look for that
Amendment
those who voted to against it
ought to get together and say how do we
make this bill better with an amendment
and then produce that Amendment and you
know I I certainly think that uh there
is enough
uh Association
professional association on the
committee that if the bill gets better
uh the committee will vote for it uh in
the in the Full House
Fellowship that's the word I was looking
representative van you had your hand up
I do I have to leave the room to go talk
to the electrician for five minutes I'll
come back and if you've got a motion on
the floor of course I won't vote I'll
wait for the next one
okay I can tell you the next bill we're
going to vote on
404. okay
which one remind me of 404 I'm sorry
which was uh election of Grafton County
Commissioners oh right okay all right
I'm gonna go talk to the electrician
I'll be right back
okay
so Mr clerk we have a tie vote on 332 at
nine to nine
and we have two authors
Thurston ready to uh some literary uh
uh wonderment that will help convince
the house one way or the other
representative McBride
ought to pass supporter and
representative majority itl right
okay the next bill that we're going to
take up an executive session is Bill
380.
380 if you remember
uh 380 with the County Commissioners and
Graft in the election of the of the
County Commission as a practice
anybody have any strong feelings would
like to make a motion on this bill Mr
chairman I move uh
OTP on House Bill 380.
that's uh from representative Tripp is
there
it's like a second from representative
Guthrie
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to make
sure everybody had a chance to read
um the testimony that representative
Smith had sent to us if you remember she
was not able to get into the meeting to
testify and she wanted to make sure that
representative you want to take a recess
did I see you nodding your head no
okay so uh we have a motion
and we have a second uh Mr clerk would
you take a role
okay Rocco vote on octopass House Bill
380. uh
representative Piemonte yes
click votes yes
representative Tripp yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative lasalles yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative yeah representative power
yes
representative Porter yes
representative 11 yes
we're back to the English
[Laughter]
yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative clay
yes
representative Gallagher
and representative chairman Dolan yes
17-0 without objection I'll place this
in the conceptual order
representative Porter do you have a
question can you show your hand up
sorry okay
I can't see it's up I'm sorry all right
oh there it was again I know
all right we're going to move on next to
remember that was the
preambulation
Bill a lot of we had a lot of discussion
a lot of uh input on that one
uh I'd like to rep like to recognize
representative Tripp for a motion
I moved uh OTP on I mean I mean I I move
itl on House Bill 404.
okay is there a second I'll second it
representative lasalles is he's the
second it's a discussion on the
preambulation bill
representative Porter I think we should
call it the The Perennial Perpetual
formulation I've dealt with this every
year
triple P bill
any other disc oh representative Manju
Puti I just want to say let's keep the
history and historic perspective and
tradition well and alive in New
Hampshire
okay
nah forget it
[Music]
I'm gonna be the only one who votes for
it because I think if it's important you
do it you do it once you get it right
and then you have a bearing to go from
and I've been out there in the woods and
I've gotten eaten by the mosquitoes and
I'm gonna vote for it and there you go
darn it give me some lemonade
can I jump in there Mr chairman for a
minute I think what you need is probably
some some off
I can't find my raised my hand so I
apologize Mr chairman but I agree with
with Jim representative uh absolutely I
did it I'm the last selectman in the
town of Salem in 2007 to walk the bounds
and the markers are clear they're there
they've never moved some of them they're
big Granite markers stamped 1890 and I'm
telling you they don't move and the fact
is if there is a border dispute then yes
you will send somebody out to verify
beyond that it's a waste of time and I'm
the last election to do it in 2007 we
walked the whole town we submitted it
it's done and we we pray we did it with
the GPS system so that it's all
documented in a complete GPS system so
again uh we need to go from the 1920s to
the 2020s
I
guess I would um
submit that we should listen to the
licensed
um surveyors they overwhelmingly
advocated for this per ambulation it's
clearly no substitute for technology and
um I think that we should defer to to
their advice so
oh thank you Mr uh rep thank you uh Mr
chair I couldn't hear you
um
first of all I think we need to all chip
in for lemonade to put into king
maggiori's crown
so he can take lemonade out with him
when he prenabulates
in his town
um I hear you representative McBride
loud and clear I know it's a pain in the
tush to do it although I've never done
it I've just heard uh yet I will not be
supporting this bill
mainly because one person said in
another person echoed it
if there's something that you're told
you should do but there's nothing that
makes you do it then you don't do it so
I think we need to say to our cities and
towns you best be paying attention to
the boundaries every seven years or so
it's good for you like lemonade thank
you
do you have uh additional comments no
representative mandatory
I just want to keep my son's elected
fence viewer position in Vermont and so
that let it live very alive in New
Hampshire okay all right uh that looks
like we finished the discussion on that
so we have a motion to itl and a second
I asked the clerk to call a roll okay
we'll call on HP 404 itl representative
Primanti yes
yes representative Tripp yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative lasalles yes
representative Melvin
yes
representative
representative power yes
representative Porter yes
representative Trey Levin
yes
representative Gilman
really you gonna ask me you just yes
yes
that's where you can go on consent
representative Davis yes
representative megapody yes
representative fan
absolutely yes
representative plea
yes
and representative Gallagher
17-1 on consent uh without objection
I'll place this on the consent calendar
no objections
our next bill and thank you all our next
bill
is going to be
has
um
and an issue that was raised
with a lot of concern from nhma that
there was a illegal a severe problem
with this bill
and uh it needs to be fixed
so uh at this point I'm going to
entertain a motion
from representative lasalles
Mr chairman I make a motion that we
retain
Bill 445
is there a second second
Ed by representative Melvin
is there any discussion
445 to retain
okay the emotion is uh Royal Call HB 445
uh representative Piemonte yes
hello folks yes
representative lasalles yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative here
representative power yes
yes
representative majority yes
Representatives Davis yeah
representative megapudi yes
representative van yes
representative Clee yes
representative Gallagher
yes
but I would like to ask for a volunteer
to work with nhma to uh
to extract a strategy of of how we
should move forward with this and what
needs to be changed in order to make it
more legal has any anyone have an
interest in this topic and would like to
work with HMA
I I would volunteer if I can do it on
virtually at least until this clarifies
I believe the point of contact would be
uh Cordell Johnson okay
all right thank you thank you for
volunteering
hey uh we're gonna need to write up why
right no it doesn't go in the calendar
if you retain it yeah we don't need it
right
yes
uh Melvin you know representative Melvin
okay the next bill we're going to take
up is Bill 459 yeah I just want to let
you know my husband just walked through
the door he's in another room after a
day of work thank you for that notice uh
I like the record uh recognize
representative piamande piamonte for a
for the recommendation of an amendment
for 459 okay I I make a motion for us to
pass his Amendment uh zero it's two
1-0250h
and that clarifies if you want me to go
into that yes please if it clarifies the
issue of standing uh and it's the bill
itself said in words a situation anyone
in the state could have standing on this
uh
not come from that particular town and
the amendment changes that to anyone can
have standing in the State but has to
come from the town that uh needs the
specification
Wilson's been made and seconded by
representative McBride on the amendment
uh thank you Mr chair just clarify what
that Amendment does the zero or one on
is this this is the one right you have a
line item which says zero or one to be
able to put yeah so what does the
amendment clarify it uh allows standing
but you have to you you can't just be
from any town to uh file a complaint on
the situation okay and you have to be
from the town like from Nashua you would
have to be from natural or from Chester
you would have to be from Chester you
couldn't be from Nashua and file a
thank you you're welcome
yeah can I just get that number again
yes it's two one dash zero two
representative Porter had her hand up
yes Mr chair once again the amendment
improves the bill
so it would be good to pass the
amendment
in my opinion
okay
all right uh I'd like to ask the clerk
to pick a role on the amendment only
okay uh vocal vote HP 459 Amendment zero
two five zero h
a
representative Tripp
yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative Rosales yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative there representative
power yes
representative Porter
yes
representative Trey Levin
representative Gilman
yes
representative majority yes
representative Davis
yeah
representative yes
representative van
yes
representative clay yes
representative Gallagher yes
and Shannon Dolan yes
18-0
okay the amendment passes 18-0 so I'd
like to like to look for a motion
so uh OTP 459 as amended
I'll make a motion on
house bill459
OTP as amended with zero two five zero
and we have a second from representative
Melvin
any discussion
I'm too I'm too fast on that raise your
hand thing
um
I will be voting against this bill
as I vote for against any bill that
seeks to be punitive against a local
official who's a volunteer and force
them to face Court charges that they
themselves have to pay for because
somebody believes they have done
something
that they don't like
um I think it's I think it's a chilling
um action to take especially in small
towns where we have a hard time finding
volunteers for the zero salary positions
to know you might be in a position where
if you do something someone doesn't like
you'll be brought to court and you have
to pay for it yourself
I also believe because I've served on
boards my husband served on boards
most of us in this room have served on
boards that we don't do things on
purpose
um to be evil and do things against the
taxpayers because we're all taxpayers
and I think this is just a slap in the
face to those people who volunteer their
job their time to make their communities
better so for that reason I'll be voting
okay I have one question I have to take
uh we're in a voting mode for this
executive
it's my interpretation we cannot pause
this
Madre I'm putting that to you or anybody
I think we're in the voting mode
so we cannot pause voting at this time
so
anybody else have any comments
I do uh Mr chair representative
trelelevin here
um I'm with representative Porter and
the part of this bill that gets me the
most is the sentence that says upon a
good faith belief
that a County City town or other local
government entity
has violated well who's to say what my
good faith belief is versus
your good faith belief or representative
trips good Faithfully for anyone else's
good faith belief I think this is a
pretty poorly written Bill the amendment
May improve it and it may have been well
intentioned but it's
not a good bill it's long it's
complicated and it it does attack
individuals unnecessarily who who are
does anybody else want to speak on this
I I just want to second that the
comments that made by my previous
um and I think it is very punitive and
at times when we need citizen
legislators good citizens uh working at
all levels of government
who live in that fear of being taken to
court
because somebody else's good faith is
not my good thing so that is hitting one
against the other and um that's not this
is not the time for it and I would not
okay thank you uh representative plee
uh thank you Mr chair um my I guess my
comment is I I'm almost just saying
ditto but I can say that as being an
alderman in Nashville we have a hard
time getting uh volunteers to sit on the
zoning board or various other boards we
literally beat sometimes we have to beat
the bushes to get volunteers and I'm
sure all the towns especially small
towns have the same thing and if anybody
has this anxiety that something is going
over there hanging over their head I
know our zoning board already has a
little anxiety about different types of
things so uh for those reasons I do
agree I think this is well intentioned
but I I I fear that we're going to just
push um
volunteers away and I don't want to see
that happen we need more people in
government
thank you very much
spirited bill
I feel that it is a bill that
that
assumes wrongdoing
on the part of volunteers for public
office when there may be no wrongdoing
but the burden of proof would rest
on those who are charged as opposed to
those who charge them and that to me is
contrary to everything that I understand
about our justice system and about good
government so I will not support this
bill
hey representative Maggiore
have you already spoke
okay I'm sorry that's that's quite all
right I'll be very brief first of all
this game is a shock to me this bill
because the town of Northampton is
always has never transferred something
into a line that had that was zeroed out
we had a legal opinion on that because
of a question raised by the budget
committee so had this if this bill ended
before Roman 2 under the under the new
section I I probably would be okay with
it but now cannot vote for this for the
same reason that representative true
Levin has pointed out and would add any
citizen of the state
aggrieved not of your town not of your
county any citizen of the state
aggrieved
um this this is an overreach and is uh
uh I will Echo what Representatives
Davis said mean spirited so I cannot
support this bill as it has been
presented thank you representative
Piemonte oh yeah representative uh
majority uh that uh amendment clarifies
that
um
it only takes precedence if it's in your
are there any I apologize representative
um I'd just like to thank you Mr chair
um I would just like to Echo um the
comments that have been made against
this bill and uh but I'll add on to one
of the things that I don't like is the
um
requirement that the court act within 10
days and most of our they'll say these
kind of land use or legislative or
Municipal uh
um bills would go to the top of the list
or be as soon as possible but this one
is actually directing the court to act
within a specific amount of time and I
don't I find that Troublesome that we
interfere with the judicial branch that
way
okay thank you any other comments before
we go to a vote
okay I like to call a vote
on
House Bill 459 as amended
okay this is uh HP 459 Auto pastors
Amendment
representative Piemonte yes
collect votes yes
representative Tripp now
representative lasauce yes
representative McBride
uh as in just through the amendment no
the bill as amended all right I'm voting
no the amendment already passed all
right yeah no I'm voting now
representative representative
no
representative 311
representative Gilman no
representative majority yeah
Representatives Davis oh
Representative mangaputi no
representative van
no
representative clay
representative Gallagher
no
okay with that failure
and across the committee anybody
Mr chair I would vote House Bill 459 in
expedient to legislate background
itl up by or mojore I remember my
jewelry and seconded by
Davis
Representatives Davis
any discussion
seeing none ask the clerk to call the
roll
representative pimonte
now
collect votes no
representative trip yes
representative Guthrie no
Representative lasalles no
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin now
representative AF representative power
no
yes
representative Gilman
representative majority yes
representative stavis yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative van yes
representative clay
yes
representative Gallagher
and chairman Dolan
no
so
that means that house bill 459
is recommended to itl player vote of
11-7 do we have a uh someone to
volunteer to write up the majority
I will volunteer
representative status volunteers we have
a representative rather a volunteer to
yamante will write them something here
yeah and I think that that's the last I
think we're gonna now take up Bill 586
which is the um
if you remember it is the bill that has
to do with Workforce housing training or
planning board and so forth
um
and this is one this is one of our three
early bills so it can't be put on
so at this point I'm gonna I'm gonna
look for a uh a motion by representative
piamonte uh I make a motion Movie retain
house bill 586.
Melvin seconds
discussion
the clerk to call the rule
I'm sorry that I see Hands waving
crown on representative mangiori
uh I might defer to representative
Porter but I'll probably ask the same
question can I ask why
sure can
I uh feel that there's no representation
for uh the actual citizen involved in
this it's geared strictly towards the
um developers and uh they have no uh
no representation for the smaller towns
and I was inundated
uh from the small towns and they said
that they don't want their landscape
changed they would like to decide to do
that
um
I
a little deeper and I saw that I felt
that you had to have both uh components
here for it to work
um
the workforce housing and the elderly
um if you have one it does it fails to
work
so uh what would be the solution to that
I'm not sure maybe an ordinance stating
that uh the town may have enough workout
for US housing court you have a
statement of fact
and it creates a situation where the
development cannot accept the uh
statement of fact and he takes to court
it takes account of Court uh that can be
done done a number of times and create a
a big problem with your budget you know
just to pay for it so I think there's a
little bit of work needs to be done on
this yet uh along those lines so that's
why I asked to retain it okay
I definitely think that we should not
retain this bill my understanding of
this the history of this bill is that
this committee looked at it last year
and has made the appropriate fixes and
I'd also like to remark that those
letters from the small towns came from
one town primarily I did not find in my
inbox an overwhelming uh
cross-section of disapproval of this and
speaking professionally as a person who
does this for a living I think this bill
goes a long way towards
stepping Us in the right direction to
solve the problem of our missing 25 000
housing units
um of course the towns still have a vote
they still have a planning board they
still get to weigh in and I think that
any town that is offering a density
bonus for housing for the elderly should
definitely
um provide that same density bonus for
other kinds of housing otherwise we're
privileging uh
we're not privileging the people that we
need as well as the people as the
elderly I'm not for punishing the
elderly but I think it's wrong to
privilege them above
you know people who are starting out in
life people in middle age who got
divorced and need some place to live I
think that as I said earlier this
morning in my earlier testimony only 20
of our
of our housing units our households our
families with children and there are
lots of people who could be benefited by
the housing that this bill steps Us in
the direction that we need to go so I am
definitely opposed to the itl thank you
uh yeah please help my memory who who
seconded the motion
I did Melvin okay thank you well Melvin
yeah
actually we both did and representative
yeah so
I yeah I got those same emails too since
they came to all of us and
my reaction to them was it they actually
their
um opposition to them actually hardened
my resolve to support them because a lot
of the arguments they're making against
it
seemed to me uh
if they're they they were expressing
disdain for my district so
I I represent Concord Ward 6 which is a
downtown area very high density I live
in a public housing apartment a 10th
floor a 10-story building the JFK
building and
which is all low-income housing and for
them to
for all these opponents of it to
complain about low-income people I I
just felt that was like a personal
attack on me and
it just strengthened my resolve to
provide housing for people despite their
objections
uh representative Porter
thank you Mr chair
um I felt when we were hearing the
testimony this time that we really
it was unfortunate that we didn't give
more of the history of this bill and
serving on the subcommittee with you on
this bill last term I want to give some
information to the new people on the
committee the first thing was that this
bill
the original two bills that we dealt
with last year came from the governor's
task force on housing
and it came they came to us and they had
a lot of problems
we had a hearing we listened to the same
kinds of problems identified in the
emails that you you all got as well as
other issues that are concerns about
zoning boards and planning boards and
and
um a myriad of things and we had all
those complaints in front of us when we
met as a subcommittee and in that
subcommittee we had all the stakeholders
participating we had this office of
strategic initiatives we had uh Ben
Frost with the Housing Finance Authority
we had
um Alyssa miracle and who works with
housing action New Hampshire we had
Cordell Johnston to make sure that we
weren't stepping on uh toes up and
taking away Authority from local
communities
and there were other people in the room
and as we worked we identified the
problems that people had brought up and
that group of people worked together to
provide to
structure the language of the bill so
that nothing in the bill everything that
had been brought up to us as a problem
was addressed in the bill and every
single person that was part of that
stakeholder group approved of the final
bill as amended we brought it forth to
our committee and it passed the
committee
and it it went on and passed the house
we worked so hard
and I feel that those emails that came
from I know two communities
that were there that get all those
emails and I I've driven photos lovely
Farm communities and I understand what
they're saying but this bill does not
prevent them from or force them to do
anything they everything that's in the
bill is incentivized if a community
chooses to do this they can do it and
here's a tool and a way that you can do
it if your community does not want to do
it your community does not have to do it
and the only restriction on that was the
housing for the elderly the density
benefits for the housing of the elderly
if you gave that in your community then
you had to do it for affordable housing
and if you didn't want to do that then
just rescind it for the housing for the
elderly there was nothing in this bill
that forces any Community to do anything
that they don't want to do so I I
understand that we got a lot of emails
but I think those people were
misinformed about the true nature of
this bill and so I'm asking you to think
about what you're doing the governor
supports this bill this is a bipartisan
effort it's not a democratic thing it's
not a republican thing it's a state of
New Hampshire we're in a crisis and we
need to have something
to help our communities who want to to
make good choices for the kinds of
housing that they develop in their
communities and this bill does that and
so now that I'm all red in the face and
my blood pressure is Sky High I'm gonna
shut up and let you take your vote thank
you for your comments uh representative
lasalles had a comment
yes I'm a co-sponsor of this bill and I
support the bill for all the reasons
that representative Porter just
mentioned
I live in the beautiful town of
Litchfield
uh those of you who do not know
Litchfield know that at one point it was
a farming Community but it has become a
bedroom community
and it has become a bedroom community
for wealthy people and people who are
over 55. we have about a dozen over 55
communities in the town of Litchfield
and we have all of these Mansions as
people call them uh at the same time a
young person who was just starting out
in life uh doesn't really have a chance
to live in the town of Litchfield
because there's nothing that's
affordable for them
I also am a selectman in town and I know
that there is
there is a need
for
Workforce housing I'm not going to say
low-income housing I'm going to say
Workforce housing so just as we have
over 55 communities I would like to see
us have under 35 communities or under 40
communities I also work as a substitute
teacher in the local high school
and one day I had I was had a chat with
one of the young teachers and I said uh
you know where do you live she said
Goffstown or something I said well why
don't you move to Litchfield she said
I'd love to live live in Litchfield but
I can't afford to live in the gym
so I I think it's time for the for the
towns to step up to the plate we have a
crisis here in New Hampshire
I I have a friend who lives he's a
neighbor of mine and he works for the
state people who works to
to
recruit companies from out of state to
come to the answer
one day I ask him what what are the
issues that keep businesses from moving
to New Hampshire he says two things
overwhelmingly two things one is the
cost of energy we all know that
secondly is the availability of
Workforce and when you break that down
the availability of Workforce is really
harmed by the fact that you can't get a
decent place to live for under uh
fifteen hundred dollars a month so yes
I'm a co-sponsor of this bill I'm proud
of being a co-sponsor of it and I'll
support it
thank you Mr chair I've been searching
frantically for my copy of the bill and
it seems to have vaporized
um
I don't know where it's gone but I did
have some notes on it and I've recalled
a few of them one of them is I felt like
a lot of those emails that came to us
were from people who were very
misinformed about what that bill was
going to do for them what this bill is
going to do for them or do to them or
what they were going to have to do in
regards to it and I think that that's
unfortunate my understanding is that
it's an enabling Bill and after
listening to representative Porter and
representative
lasalles um I I can't um
I'll be supporting the Bill thank you
thank you uh representative mangaputi uh
thank you Mr chair my recollection of uh
the testimonies and um I was very
encouraged with the fact that this is a
very enabling bill and when we are in
the middle of the crisis of housing
shortage acute housing shortage and
especially Workforce housing and
commissioner Caswell said Governor uh
sunun they all supported it and this is
a critical need and uh you know knowing
it is a critical need and it's the right
Bill to bring in and I got a lot of
emails too it just highlighted I moved
into a bedroom community and I don't
want the density to increase the reason
I moved here I'm one at quaint little
town so
we I think I would strongly support and
this is not the bill to be retained or
itl this is the bill that needs to pass
to give the tool that the
communities need
to enable the acute shortage so I
request that we vote on it thank you
thank you representative Maggiore
oh whoops uh thank you Mr chair I've
become a one-trick pony when it comes to
discussing this bill because I refer
back continuously to my first term when
it was 1629 and 1632 and I was I don't
know that I've ever taken that many
notes and that made that many comments
on a bill and was one of the
I'm going to say at least from my own
perspective one of the staunchest
opponents of that bill as it was
presented and and would have been
probably as upset as representative
Porter is now had that bill passed
um but this bill as it has been
presented and as and as it was amended
satisfied the concerns that I have and
it's why when it we every time the bill
came up I voted against every comment I
would I voted against this bill though
fixed all of those concerns I have been
a member of the select board in
Northampton for four terms and remember
and the representative to the planning
board for eight of those years
um this alleviates my concerns that I
have so I can I support 586 I I wish we
could take an up or down vote on it now
thank you Mr chair
Senator clay
um one of the things I hear quite often
is kicking the can down uh the road
many of you worked on this bill over the
over the years and I hear
um representative majority and
representative Porter talk about how how
much work went into it to put in those
changes and to do all that was needed to
do I think if we kick this can down the
road and retain it only to discuss it
again after it's been discussed pardon
my language here at nauseam
um is really doing a disservice for all
those that did so much work last year
and this was basically just put on hold
because of the pandemic or we call it
the death of the covid
um
this is my third term and I very rarely
hear our governor come out and speak
in favor or against a bill as as much as
he seemed to on this particular one
um the fact that it's got bipartisan
support the fact that we've got
governmental I mean Governor support Mr
casual support I really think that we
should take a vote I hope we take a vote
on to pass but I think in all fairness
we really need to take a vote on another
note I did respond to some of those
emails that we got and I asked them
Point Blank did you know that this is
not the original bill from the previous
year that it was the um massage bill as
I referred to it that changes had been
made and changes had been put in
without failure none of them knew that
they only knew of the bill that had hit
last year and they said that they were
opposed to it so I think much like what
representative majority had said you
know it was not a good bill it was a bad
Bill you all fixed it and I think one of
the questions and clarifications that
representative Porter brought forward
during the question is is this the
change bill is this the modified bill
and the answer was yes which kind of
sealed the deal for me
um I think you all did the work and I
think we should pass this bill thank you
uh thank you I also was on the committee
when this bill originally came to us and
was
very firmly against it in the form that
we received it uh and but it became
convinced after the work the
subcommittee did on it that it that it
in fact epitomized the way things are
done in New Hampshire and shouldn't be
done in New Hampshire which is namely if
your community doesn't wish to do this
it doesn't have to do this if your
community wishes to do this we now
provide you with a tool and a mechanism
to be able to do it better and more
efficiently here in Lebanon where I live
an affordable housing situation is
upwards of two thousand dollars a month
uh there are nurses and LPNs at
Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical Center who
cannot afford to live here it is a
travesty it is a shame and it has a
negative impact on all of us I strongly
support this bill
thank you uh last comment of
Representative mangaputi yeah you know
how I go back to the blue sheet yes this
has 36 support and 11 of those and two
neutral so that strengthens my
of support to this bill knowing that
there were 36 people who supported this
bill and it's a good bill
okay so we have a motion and a second
before us to retain uh I'd like to ask
the clerk to call a roll
okay uh HB 586
uh representative pimonte yes
click folks yes
representative Tripp yes
representative Guthrie yes
Representative lasalles no
representative McBride no
uh representative representative power
yes
representative Porter yeah
representative Trail 11 no
representative Gilman
no
representative majority
Representatives Davis no
Representative mangaputi no
representative van no
representative clay
no
representative Gallagher
uh
12 to six motion fails
in motion to retain fails of be looking
for our new motion at this point just a
chair I move to pass a second second
you have a motion from representative
Porter ought to pass and who was making
a second I think lava and I were tied
yeah
I I yield to my colleague Davis
as the second
any further discussion
got it
I'll ask the uh before I ask the clerk
to call a roll I do want to comment that
I understand
bills like this are very emotional can
make your face red
yeah
it wasn't
we have a fellowship
reality that allows us to navigate
through some of these tough bills
emotional bills sometimes partisan uh
bills so I I compliment you all on a
respectful
and
having a strong convictions but still
being respectful to each other so I'll
I'll call ask the clerk to call the role
on the ottp motion Mr chair before we do
I just want to say I'm an Italian
okay a hundred percent so I have that
way I'm sorry if I offended anybody with
my strength of of forcefulness of
discussion
okay
let's all remember that we're
all
maintain your convictions
but I just ask you to be respectful what
you have been I'm comp that's a
compliment to the committee so thank you
all yeah this is my sugar level tubing
Clark to call the roll please okay uh
off to pass on 586.
uh Representative no
but yes uh representative Tripp yes
president Guthrie yes
representative lasalles yes
uh representative McBride yes
representative
yes
representative fan
please yes
representative Gallagher
yes
Kevin Dolan yes
Ocean passes 15 degrees
15-3
okay well I thank you all for enduring a
very long day uh and we're we're we have
next Monday off as a holiday so we're
gonna we've been moved next week to
Thursday so you should see you should
have seen that in the calendar so we
will see you next Thursday may I ask a
right ahead thank you so much and I'm
sorry for the delay
um I volunteered to do a majority report
for hb459
and I just wanted to verify what I'm
writing is the majority report for HP
right that's true okay great I'm glad
I'm glad you brought that up though
because we do need volunteer to write
the majority report on 586
and also I'm a volunteer to write the
minority
usually it's the person that makes the
motion
so I would be glad to write the majority
report on 586 I would gladly accept any
help from anybody who wants to help
and uh representative will write The
Minority Report
representative Powell do you have
additional questions
yeah
sorry Mr chairman I wanted to point out
if I'm not mistaken that our our time of
meeting for Thursday is 8 A.M and not 9
A.M which is different than what we've
been doing
just so people take note of that is that
correct
I would have been an hour late thanks
for reminding you too yeah
past 15 to 3.
Christine can you repeat that
uh Mr chair
volunteered to work with uh Mr Johnson
cardale I'm on uh Cordell Johnson on uh
yeah
could you just give me the contact or
how do I go about who's going to contact
who I'll help you with that glasses
thank you thank you thank you so uh
represent uh representative Andrew uh Mr
cordelli Rose
wrote a uh a rather lengthy opinion
so I would
talk to him and get a copy of what he
wrote and then get his opinion and then
the intent would be to meet with them uh
a legal advisor in OLS and have uh have
that legal question opposed to see if uh
again if there is an illegality in it
and if it does need to be fixed or is is
uh
um uh is that being misread by him and
is there is there a fix that needs an
amendment uh to change the bill and
what's the time frame within which I
need to get it done
right so yeah so it's not okay thank you
thank you that clarifies and I just want
to compliment you on your uh
chairmanship that has this has really
given me uh comfort
and knowing that we can agree to
disagree but and stay very professional
and very cordial that really has
reassured the bipartisan if that's still
is
around and respective Mr chair I have
one question yes
by May
um
and also a comment that this is the best
Committee in the House of
Representatives
pardon me that's because of all of you
uh well who knows maybe it's magical
powers but it is the best one
um could Christina repeat what she said
just a few minutes ago about meeting
times
about what was the question meeting
times or our next meetings there was
some logistical information that I
missed I think I had said
Representatives Davis that I had noticed
on the public hearing notice for
Thursday February 18th that we are to
commence at 8 A.M and not at 9 00 a.m as
we have been doing in the past
so just for committee members to to
notice that and that was that um was
that anticipated or was that an
oversight
uh it hasn't technically been noticed in
the calendar yet so if you want to
change that I think we probably could
yes uh Christina could you change it to
9 A.M
okay I received something that said 8am
um and it went it didn't get scheduled
um but I just looked in the calendar and
um it hasn't been noticed yet it'll go
in this week's calendar and because it's
only Tuesday I think we have some time
but I'll let you know if something
happens but I think it shouldn't be a
problem good call Representative power I
noticed that number from
um
Heather gooley who's our Administrative
Assistant I don't know if that's the
correct word for her and I was going to
mention it as well so thanks for
bringing it up and I'd prefer nine
o'clock wouldn't you
yeah thanks
we're especially requested we avoid PJs
at the next meeting well
yeah
all right so any other comments or
questions
again thank you for your hard work today
and of those of you representative clay
you had anything that you wanted to say
yes the um
the this
is also for the executive session starts
at 1 30 would we be leaving that for 1
30 if we're going to be starting the
um
I think uh Christine if you're still on
uh we could move the executive session
to two Okay uh let me just double check
and make sure that that looks good and
thank you
okay everybody Joe drive carefully if
you if you're going to be on the road
and representative manager you had
anything you wanted to say a few minutes
were you crying on or anything I had
nothing of value so I I will just see
commit